you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes I hear that Bell and I'm ready to
fight Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up
they want the boat they don't work
enough don't mess around end up hurting
them I say the wrong thing make it
personal you say the wrong thing we are
live what's up fam welcome to UFC 287
Calabasas fight campaign and we have a
doozy for you folks it's just as good as
the main event Pierre Izzy it's going
down and to my left my partner in crime
was very old and very gay
Brian the gay man Callan across from me
is Ecuador's royalty over there it is
the Assassin himself Chito Vera one of
the best in the world doing it yeah
fresh off fresh off of flight from New
York hang out with action Brunton all
week didn't give me the new bounce
collab but we'll talk later and directly
across from me is the one the only he
didn't bring his tin foil hat it is Sam
Tripoli yes dude one of the funniest
mothers not gonna talk anything
conspiracies tonight the hell you are
Sam's right about everything oh no Sam
is the best uh 900. one of the best
guests to have on because if you guys
aren't here if you know if there's a
little law in there it's like dude JFK
Junior are you kidding me that oh
no dead air zero dead air I told a
friend was coming here and they said the
name of the people and they said the
Lord of conspiracies that's what my
friend told me I say that's Santa it's
an intimidating Bravo One a one B I
don't believe in them but he does but
now I'm starting to learn like that the
more I have to disagree then I learned
some stuff and I'm like damn he might be
right about everything so here's how it
goes I tell Brian something he yells at
me in a very Queeny way and then then uh
two weeks later a guest on Joe Rogan
show says the exact same thing
everybody's like interesting he's like
wow Samuel yeah I'm like okay I know I'm
so disrespectful and just like just so
you know Cheetos they do a show called
Conspiracy social uh Club where Sam
knows he has his black belt to the 10th
degree when it comes to conspiracies and
Brian's kind of a [__] when it comes to
that stuff because his dad because his
dad was in the CIA so he's like defense
I'm just saying you don't you don't
entertain
my wife this kid Dynamite so she's 33.
she used to date black athletes in
college I'm sure she's over it though
I'm sure she doesn't whisper sweet
stories in the bronze here
oh tell me about Jerome again let me
talk to you listen everybody's entitled
to be a [__] for a while and then she
decided my joke is she got tired of
riding Dolphins sometimes you want to
row a boat uh she got tired
Dolphins aren't black right no but you
know okay yeah you gotta Workshop
think of a black animal Cheeto listen I
I want to get that secret riding black
panther so she decided to go with a frog
it's not bad Judo I gotta I wanna I'm
gonna give you my my picks because I
you're one of my favorite Fighters and I
want to go through yeah I love you buddy
he's just I'm anyway but but so here's
my uh here's my assessment I'm going I'm
kicking with the main event okay can we
do the whole card first just the main
card let's do the main card bring on the
main card Rosa Junior kicks the card off
he's the 18 year old long face kid he is
a straight Savage straight Savage he's
got Bert nerdinos right
you gotta go do you feel any type of you
know a lot of UFC fighters how it goes
kind of like comics where you see
somebody getting something before maybe
certain guys have to earn the main card
spot this is what second fight and he's
kicking off on the biggest pay-per-use
get yours man I don't get why people get
upset I we talked about this before it's
you know he's in that position he was in
the right town the same place the
[__] kid talks talks crazy says
everybody
very skill on the ground can't fight his
ass off why not you should be happy for
for people like that if you hate that
you will never make it agree no that's
right it's a tough fight for him though
like don't get it twisted this isn't
like give me fight for him in any facet
like so the UFC's credit they're like
we'll put you on the main card but
you're fighting Christian Rodriguez
who's no punk man like he's not gonna
he's not gonna now if he mops the floor
with this guy it is Off to the Races for
this 18 year old but I think it's gonna
be a decision but he's gonna he's gonna
do work you guys think though that 18's
a little young to be in this big card
this is what I think fighting wise I
think about damage since this age you're
already fighting at the high level
that's right you might don't pass 30.
you might go crazy to 25 Maybe
Champion whatever
but the amount of damage it would take
to get to the fight and you start at 18
in the UFC at 18 I was fighting in
Mexico for 300 bucks yeah getting
experience not dealing with Savages like
again for him to only have a certain
amount of fights and he's fighting
Christian Rodriguez the main card like
this is he's not gonna not get clipped
right like it's gonna be a problem like
you want to get the experience what
happened to chase Hooper you correct
I was six one on one that's no
experience no but now I have 21 fights I
just figured it out yours yours is
interesting you know what I'm saying
yours is interesting and similar to
Charles Oliver where it's like they you
guys like you were you you kind of got
your experience in the UFC which is rare
because most guys get that experience
they lose three and they're out and they
have to go do work on a regional circuit
and jump back in like when I was when I
was fighting the UFC my first Main Event
Ultimate Fighter had three fights I was
fighting Roy Nelson six months later I'm
fighting Gabriel Gonzaga for my fifth
fight and then pass another and then
with my whatever eighth fight I'm
fighting Merkel Crow comp in the ninth
fight I'm fighting no Guerra so it's
like so crazy
slow down but people don't understand
that they have no idea you see you
losing yeah and they say this
you good that was early and those
[__] were fighting their whole
entire life they're kind of highest
level correct that's what when I met
when I when I started looking up to
fight in the US I wasn't thinking of
fighting the UFC I want to fighting
Legacy I want to fight in our fight you
know yes video shows that have cameras
and bright lights because and
competition's still good it's so good
yeah that was funny in Panama in Peru it
was a tough guys but
I was coming out of Ecuador trading in
the living room yep
I wish I got to at least 15 or 25 before
yep because I got pretty damn well
because because what they but but
cheeto's an insulin because again he's
one of the rare guys who outlier but who
gained his experience at the highest
level it usually he's an outlet usually
it does not work out for people like
it's such a and they always say like in
the UFC like unless you're ready to go
to make around the title do not come to
you he's one of those guys who come gets
better in the Big Show competition
because a lot of guys freeze up and I
think I feel like because you're such an
adrenaline junkie the lights and
everything you're just like this I'll
say this Judo you know I love the piss
out of you your your last fight it
didn't seem like the Cheeto we know it
you didn't seem like you like I was I
was like because you always start slow
and then it comes how's it come on
am I off no you're you're [__] it's
like easily we talked before I came here
I said this before and I will say it
again I'm not the guy that even if I
have the actual facts it will sound as
an excuse me when I say
that's what what I would say I would say
off camera off record but yeah it was it
was I lost that was it took me I'm not
blaming coaches or problem with
neighbors I don't blooming wife friends
Tony Camp was great I know the train
Camp was great it wasn't I was [__]
betting I was putting my own house paper
just that night and that exact time I've
been there which is like man if we could
just do this any other day you beat this
dude you know I just don't feel like
check yourself you know when in the in
the horror movies when you're turning
the car on and Jason have to fight my
chat about to [__] cut your head off
thinker goes
that was me you just couldn't get at
some point I told my coach hey man I'm
gonna fight my ass off
I know you're frustrated me too but it's
not on us tonight there's nothing
there's a clip of perilla saying in the
corner
to to the other corner of the months yo
he's flat as a drone yep he got no sip
on the punches when I saw that I was
like
yeah and that's what like to me like I
can come up with crazy stories or just
[__] it just doesn't sound right that's
what you think it was I mean like so
like I I don't drink I don't do anything
so when I like let's I'll have like one
thing that I normally don't have I can
feel it affect my body was there
something that you did differently that
just was off that that's a good question
but Sam have you and like his job is to
fight grown men in steel cage in his
underwear your jobs do stand-up comedy
have you ever got to stage and like
before just like man for whatever it is
usually we love it nothing better
there's whatever it's that one show it's
a sold out crowd you have no reason not
to be up for it you're just like I just
don't that'll happen and then you're not
clicking for whatever reason 100 it's no
different with fighting I just some
football players like they don't have to
you know capitalize like he does in a
single fight but like trust me Tom Brady
some of those games where you see that
he's off he doesn't feel like playing
football the crazy the crazy thing is
like like even in between rounds I was
standing up I don't even take a seat in
between runs like not once
coach was like yo you're not even
breathing like are you okay like are you
okay because I'm like coach
I'm trying my brain is here my balls are
here but my body is failing today yeah
like it's just it just happens it's just
today that that because it's like I was
punching in the air and he was running
and he was out out positioning me I was
in front of him yeah I I track him
probably better than anybody before
without even on the tables I mean I
wasn't even defending detective no he's
not big it's almost like those crazy
dreams when you're trying to kill the
guy that rap your mom and this punches
and stop right before or you're like in
water yeah you just feel like you're in
water yeah it just happens I was I was
I'm I'm not cool with it it [__] make
my God [__] boil but I'm just like
it's okay we go back to the gym where is
it's all you handle it right you can
control that at least you didn't go in
there and you felt the best you've ever
felt you performed the best you ever
felt you're firing all cylinders and he
just outclassed you that's different
then it's like oh we're never sniffing
the title this is like no and I could
when you were yeah I'm like oh cheers
left because there's there's people that
text me like yo did you purposely did
that I said like come on yeah
but it's like yeah you just it just
happened at night you know it's all good
and at least you didn't get injured and
get beat up I don't think anybody who
competes on that level especially in in
MMA doesn't have a night like that I
mean it's rare or or that it might start
off like that and then something happens
in the second round where it comes to
them and I feel like that happened
to most at the high level happens every
other 10 competitions which is one night
you were a leader of yeah I don't have
excuse me with the Travis Brown thing
Josh Brown I just wanted to stop doing
it Roy Nelson was the biggest one and I
was on the fee at the time on the main
event Jon Jones is a co-main event a
main event against reut in Vegas all my
family's there am I coming forever but
but outside that even my my coach on the
back like what's wrong with him like I
don't know what to tell you man I just
don't feel like doing this like yeah
well if we could fight tomorrow I I
think I'd win tonight it's gonna be
trouble that's a crazy part I felt that
before electronically tonight's gonna be
trouble I'll give it my all cause we got
ready to do a couple bumps you know you
know what's crazy I don't even feel like
that I actually felt I actually pushed
myself to feel good but when I really
realized I wasn't good because when I
was warming up in the morning for the
ShakeOut when I was starting like the
power was there but when I was kicking I
was feeling out of balance and normally
at that day I'm [__] Bruce Lee I'm
[__] whipping kicks coming on my
brain Confidence from it yeah and then
I'll I kind of look at gosh I'm like I'm
a little balanced today and he said like
don't worry about it don't even think
about it like cool because what is the
worst what happened you just gotta fight
your ass off yeah and I did that
I pressure the whole fight
I I don't have a bruise after the fight
yeah I wasn't even limping it's crazy I
think humble was limping a little bit
but
yeah how do you think and then Corey
called out uh marab after the fight how
do you think that goes for him
I think I think my rap will get a hold
of him non-stop Rob's a problem
that flight because Corey does get tired
Cody gets get tired waiting for me
get to shoot the 48 times like he did
for five rounds John have a better gas
tank than Corey so I would say he will
harm him for a lot of time
but I got like mirab needs to fight like
somebody will get him trouble somebody
that can keep the cardio like even when
he was taking me down and I wasn't even
trying to defend I was like I got elbows
I got I put him on a travel once but it
was it was a weak one yep but it's like
with maraba you know him versus Corey it
can be the benefit for Corey if it's
three rounds yes because I'm five
against Morocco I don't care who against
anybody it's gonna be tough man he's a
tough I look forward to that at one
point just for the challenge of it
because I know I I can't guarantee a win
because I'm not a [__] delusional guy
but I say this I won't get tired against
the guy you want yeah with you you'd be
one of his toughest matchups not saying
that just because you're here but
because marab you know the stand-up uh
Danger's not really there against you
for him you know like you he you don't
have to be worried about getting knocked
out but it was so heavy it was heavy but
you can see it's one shot and it's to
lead him into the takedown but for him
he you know he if he gets those
takedowns first second third round you
you have knocked out power in the fourth
and fifth which for him is an issue
which is he just get tired of being
correct I used when when he fought John
John seems like he just left the Soul at
the home like I don't know what happened
in the Miley fight he looked off in this
fight look of it's almost like maybe he
gets too famous and he couldn't handle
it maybe once he got money in the pocket
this is like chilling it might be that
or it could be also to him being screwed
over by the judges like back to back if
he probably just lost the passion
remember he's he's threatening to just
go fight and Russia that happened to me
again yeah even it's probably a little
worse my decision was even worse than
his this is really bad I came but
[__] wanted to kill the war yep I
said [__] you I think maybe because his
was back to back he's like all right I'm
you know this is no win situation for me
here but maybe that but you know sugar
talks a lot of [__] but he goes since
Peter Young fought me because you guys
can say what you want but I took that
man's heart it's like it's not lying
yeah it hasn't been the same since that
fight yeah that's true he's been but but
even in that fight he got he got tied in
you know three to rounder which is
normally fight five rounders yeah maybe
he's [__] her wrong maybe he's
getting a little too much drinking too
much power yeah who knows what's going
on in people's lives something's going
on though 100 definitely she's a Savage
bro if I was 19 but he's 18. 18. I mean
it's weird to have that kind of
conclusion so everyone has uh uh wrote
Rosa yeah you gotta go with a young guy
you have to just for the [__] of it the
hype and you I I I like good stories
like nothing's better than a Fighter's
come up like Conor's come up was
ridiculous uh sugars was fun like when
those guys are coming up Izzy's was
great Francis was great so I like to
come up so I want this kid to be the
next big thing it's fun yeah yeah it's
fun to be like on the journey yeah
um who's uh I mean this is his physical
like what's a man's physical peak
30 30. so and that heavy weight maybe a
little later between 30 and 36 that's
about you 56 can be so he's got right
yeah oh you're 56. 56 you're just
getting started dude you know I saw I
saw a jawline that's a tiger
but it's a sensual tiger is that the
Tiger King over there yeah
yes
Roar he was so into Tigers dude
nothing's better when that girl gets her
arm ripped off by that tiger and he
rushes and he's like yeah shut the place
down and he's rushing and I thought he's
rushing to like call the cops or like
get some like medical equipment nope he
goes put on this Saucy jacket
and I was like I couldn't believe the
pressure I could barely take the
pressure now think about this with a
tiger can you imagine tiger no rip no it
ripped her arm yeah no she was like hell
in India guy went to take a picture do
you see that he takes a picture and the
thing ripped his arm off of the shoulder
sir it's like oh delicious I enjoy it
like Tiger's doing tiger [__] like
you're gonna [__] with tigers
if I see a [__] dog I'm running to
you everywhere
they there's a pit bull like two blocks
away from my house and I opened it off
my house and I see the [__] people
next to my car and I was going to my car
to grab some [__] and I was like I'm
gonna wait I guess I'm gonna grabbing
[__] I'm gonna sit this one out and then
uh
I'm like you go yeah I bet you I give
you a hundred bucks if you go and bring
my phone did you see the lady that was
like that she takes care of alligators
and she wants to go do it and it just
starts rolling here and the guy just
walks up slowly like should I help I'm
getting rolled by a Gators she survived
right that was in the tank you saw the
lady in Florida with the chimpanzee rip
her face apart but she was like sucking
that monkey off the chimpanzee
she changed her hair here
and the chip was like don't like your
hair and I'm gonna take it no but he was
outside your fingers no but she was also
she also had a romantic relationship
with him because there's a picture of
him like in a robe sipping red wine
Vicodin
they [__] and then her friend came over
and he was like I don't like your friend
your friend's real [__] blocked he'd
known him check this out your face not
anymore 230 pound chin with diabetes and
I'm gonna take your face your fingers
and your genitals because yes they do
that's a great pet the gym said your
pronouns whatever you want now
that [__] thing [__] up
at home you gotta be [__] the thing
oh yeah I mean well you know because
they can get you pregnant different DNA
that's okay I don't think that's
scientifically true no he's the he's
honest they know some [__] dude maybe
you're right well if you know they like
to rip dicks so if you don't have dicks
faces
facing hands they pull your genitals off
yeah that's their move dude that's not
good it's like a sea world I watch that
black fish documentary after I took my
kids to Sea World I'd never go back
after watching that Blackfish but they
have heavy on the black but they had a
uh the trainer she just gets mauled by
this thing yeah and Sea World on the
news was like oh no he she drowned like
that's what happened he pulled her
watering down but the actual autopsy
report came out bro he developed ripped
her [__] Scout box yeah ripped her
arms off hold on dude are you tell me a
killer whale get killed yeah no they're
the Ted monkeys
you told me about the Jaguar that killed
that woman uh that cage was open and it
bit through her skull didn't you tell
yeah oh yeah that was in Denver that was
in Denver yeah the Denver Zoo because
you have friends who actually yeah yeah
and she [__] up friends whoever was on
it left left yeah yeah yeah
well the teeth there was two like basic
bullets from his jaw going Kong yeah
that's killer it's Jaguar Jaguar someone
left the gate open while she was like
whatever scrubbing the [__] nothing's
like what's up [__] you're in my
apartment
and then killed her yeah wow that's what
these it was quick though yeah it's
quick that's much better than that do
you think they're ever going to tell you
it was slow there's a rubber oh dude she
died slow death it was painful and so
let the hot thoughts came on that side
Robert in Mexico that have a [__]
Java in-house he bought it when she was
like baby like a couple weeks yeah I'm
now dude it's no Ecuador they have them
in the forest in the 40 yeah this guy
from Mexico boarded in the forest for
like 20 grand because in order to keep
nap then you gotta [__] make sure
mommy don't kill you Jesus Christ
this guy he put it on Nike I'm like yo
that thing is hungry one time oh yeah
[__] I don't what are you gonna do
especially Jaguars especially this
you'll see that cat people who work with
big cats they don't work with Jaguars
that so so here's how it goes Tiger's
not a smart you can work with a tiger
don't fall down in front of a tiger
don't fall down can't fall down and
tigers are all different some tigers are
easy to go with other Tigers no [__]
way can't turn your back either right
you don't do certain things I mean lions
are way better because Lions have
communication so when you go in there a
lion will tell you exactly how a lion's
feeling so they're way more predictable
when you're with a line you let them
they have to do their thing with you
they have to greet you just like a pack
animal
so when you understand their behavior
it's way more predictable Jaguar is the
reason you never see Jaguars in circuses
is because Jaguars can be cool I talked
to the guy who he goes he showed me all
the scars he said a Jaguar you can walk
a jaguar or work with a Jaguar for five
years and then on a Tuesday you've been
doing the same thing and the Jaguar goes
not today and just jumps and just
attacks that's like hookers
Eastern European ones even Vegas ones
man they're cool on a Monday Thursday
okay so on Monday yeah should we just
break down what we think is going to
happen whatever time it comes out I
think roads will be a decision that next
you have Kevin Holland and uh San Diego
ponsonibio I just think Holland's Got
That Crazy Holland should get it done
but Potts neighborhood can [__] hit
man but um
too that's that's the way to do things
is my colleague that's right yeah I'm
gonna take Kevin Holland just because
he's his back's against the wall you
gotta wrestle with him
um is being heard in yeah neither one
can wrestle I'm saying but but Holland
Holland okay
from the [__] that's a young man so
east of the West
Holland but
it's too much right he he fights like
too much in a way a little bit yeah
there's zero body fat
nice
he's an arrest
good elbow like I said this is a perfect
fight for him so she kick off the main
card because this guy's not gonna be
scared of him like these other cats he's
been fighting especially let's see if he
buys this one he's gonna just get to a
place that he's gonna get just hard and
hard but look at this how old is he 18
18. what were you doing at 18 Sam
where do you learn
I discovered math yeah where'd this kid
come out of uh Mexico Mexico
is like
that shot wasn't great but yeah he's
Relentless he's younger yeah he'll try
everything yeah but he's been trained by
dad and brother which I think is going
to be bad in the long run he's gonna
have to hit with like you know you can
only go so far and it's gonna be a tough
conversation but uh yeah he's since he's
18. he doesn't specialize in like
wrestling Boxing he specializes in MMA
right like the younger crowd they're
coming up just learning MMA look at it
yeah pretty is that a good thing that's
a good thing or it's tough because when
you look at the Champions they're kind
of dominant at one thing except for Jon
Jones oh
[__]
but again I think it's good the longest
fight goes the better for Rosa Junior
it'd be bad if you work this dude in 10
seconds like he needs to get experience
in there and get in compromise positions
this guy having his back is good for his
career like he should we want you need
an experience yeah
he goes because he's young he don't give
a [__] he doesn't even know what to get
entire me yeah he haven't got tatted yet
he's 18. when I was 18 I was I wasn't
smart my seven year old plays soccer for
nine hours dude yeah it's so weird they
don't stop look at this
everything changes when you become a man
now you have pressure now you got here
to accomplish yeah
yeah dude it's mouthpiece what the [__]
it's a real veteran move to spit it out
if that young man did that
yeah no I think it was Rodriguez
boom man this kid's gotta got some rest
he's relentless
wrestling he's got batteries and roofers
in his corner there Rodriguez guy it's a
catch rate at 137 137 mm-hmm
did Rodriguez Miss way
and maybe they oh jumped on like a
Mexican spider monkey
uh oh yeah this might be over
I have body locks again it's better I
mean for the hype it's good if you
submits them in the first round but for
his career to get the experience would
be Priceless for him oh there it is
there it is he's talented as [__] oh
yeah here's a reason why he's still kick
off of this main card oh my God look at
this oh he got his arm trap his hand is
trapped
that hurts like a mother yeah that's not
comfy at all
oh he's he's safe the thing you got he
don't have experience in is you know
he's has that body triangle right now
and he's trying to get the Finish if
this guy makes out the first round it's
a lot of energy man I know this kid
doesn't get tired I might get him here
oh
damn it
two on one daddy oh sitting down like
that can't be good for the neck that's
not fun for the neck no yeah and then
he's controlling his breathing too with
that body like like that is that sucks
that's a lot of pressure to him it's not
what you look forward to that's why you
got to do some notes he's out of it
though yep again impressive
yeah every it's rare every card on the
main event or the main card is great
this fight if I'm there's not one Carver
I'm like I can take this one off it's
like some of them do you think Kevin
Holland's doing nothing but wrestling
all the time no why would he do that
because
it's a major problem for him and if he
wants longevity he's got to work on
wrestling he's not going to commit style
in a way like you can change and look
like an old Pony trick really it's a
greatest Striker but it's killer strike
did you just got to a black bone Jiu
Jitsu
he's just he's just the type that type
is long probably not it was as strong as
awkward good whip there's not enough
hours in the day for him to pick up
wrestling to compete in the UFC at that
I mean you can maybe like when you get
to UFC fine tune a couple things but you
take it on defense but you're not become
just I guess you can't just add a whole
nother I guess that's there's no way
Harry Potter I know I'm saying it lasted
30 seconds that's what I'm saying what's
he gonna do it's over yeah
there's some altercation where before he
said this he says demos wall which I
don't think you should do he goes what's
up baby girl it might as well just
freaks the [__] what's up baby girl yeah
like we're homies you don't [__] name
that's two guys are out of my head him
and bispin you say yo and if they don't
feel good right with that Joe they fight
you yeah people forget bisping's a bit
of a hot head with that stuff too like
he if you're on his good side he's the
best sometimes and I'm his friend yeah
yeah yeah
it's for foreign
one time and somebody else on the
podcast bro Flat Earth and bro he went
nuts did he yeah he's not shy of opinion
oh my God yeah
no bisbee's a Savage he don't give a
[__] I like when people compare my
career to his
house
when he beat Luke rockhold he was like
[__] you yeah yeah
those are great
fun as [__] no but people I mean Biz
Wings the the horse Gracie of uh UK
Sports man oh yeah well not to be he's
the original if you notice Bisping
started really winning a lot when drug
testing came in
I'm not saying I'm just saying I'm not
he went a lot before too though he did
yeah but I'm saying maybe the guys that
were cheating
go blind because he was on all the acai
and wheels
amazing stuff he kicked his eye off
he's you guys still want to become world
champion oh his story is insane he
fought almost 10 or 15 fights after
bitter make him blind incredible when I
had to get from [__] Super trt Bro I
was training with him at rain and I'm
like you can't see this he's like no I'm
like how the [__] are you gonna fight
you go in there and win yeah he's such a
Savage when he fought uh Silva they
caught on his face but really told me he
could see the side of the nose not one
of my favorite fights of all time crazy
great fight that's a crazy fight where
business where uh Anderson so at the end
I think it was just the flying knee yeah
oops yep oh that's folks yeah I mean a
real men don't do that [__] I agree
is a great analyst too man he's really
really really good oh he's not shy of of
saying I had his [__] sucks guys I'm
sorry he doesn't care he goes I'm sorry
if you're watching this but if I suck
yeah he tells the truth and in Spanish
they do the same thing yeah they don't
like that they they want you to leave
he's really bored as [__] they want you
to be like yeah then once you find the
best in it it's like no man like the
people at home aren't stupid especially
the hardcore fans like this fight sucks
let me just be honest yeah but that's
what people like a lot of people they
gravitate towards
um 69. so B you got you got Kevin you
got Kevin Holland or pontoon I don't
know enough about panzania I'm gonna go
with he's not a tough because
if you stand in bed
oh you're thinking of uh
what'd you say is he got three Yeah
by decision Jeff Neil bring him a
decision when he just beat morono but
morono hurt him but maroon took it on
like a three-day notice yeah because
you're supposed to fight uh Robbie
Lawler yes see see I feel like Rosa here
I think that Lawler's still going yeah
Mike Tyson yeah he did foreign
yeah this is not good for Rosa he got
tired this is good for him though for
experience yeah it's good maybe to learn
it off yeah I told you it's gonna be bug
fight for him like this wasn't a gimme
fight but this is what he needs man yeah
it is
the best thing you're fighting somebody
from contenders you're not getting
against somebody has been in the UFC for
a couple years yeah exactly it's only
the top 15 but it's still gonna be like
trying to figure it out yeah and they're
not scared of either match up well and
then also if he wins this fight you're
not you're not gonna toss them a top 15
guy that's the other thing to your point
it's fighting another Prospect and the
thing the deal with this if you lost
it's also how he had the books he's been
talking crazy yeah anybody anybody
[__] submit everybody Champion like
beat Champion he's the youngest champion
of all time is like when you lose
MMA is a ruthless it's forever you don't
I I know professional Surfers I know
people in the NBA
people took [__] finances is one-on-one
it's either they're sucking your dick
and swallow your [__] or they hate you
and say your mom is ugly so graphic and
it's fast
we're passing 10 minutes
but also yeah in fighting the the I want
to hear YouTube
he does do it that'd be so great bro on
here like he's going to suck his dick
like a producer like Cheeto can you can
you not make that reference but he's
right he's right sometimes don't say
what you yeah I swear what I want to say
nobody's right like in in no other sport
or the the Peaks and valleys like it's
either there's no middle ground fighting
there's nothing to come off the wind and
you're the best thing of all time you're
gonna have you always use your last name
that's respect yeah there is a
difference I suck this dick did you
swallow that's the next that's love do
you think if you remove a rib that's
good for MMA it's good for jiu jitsu if
you have one or a couple less ribs so
more flexibility yeah you're like hey I
can suck my own dick you're like oh
that's dangerous
yeah you don't you don't you don't want
to you need those ribs I'm guessing so
one-on-one right it'd be one-on-one yeah
this is good for him let's see how he
answers this third oh
oh that is nice elbow
good experience for this kid there's
people just [__] up there's the memes
of this kid online people oh people
they're such [__] he had a cleft
palate palette I know so I was being a
meanie earlier you didn't know though so
I didn't take it as too much offense but
then also he has that face of the the
Spanish Warrior and you can tell he is
straight his DNA is from a Spanish
Warrior it is to a [__] this is
old-school Spanish right there
no you're right man it's like I hate
people that make fun of oh that's true
look at Trump is he really there yeah
well is he second bro
how dare you dude how about this
Sterling Nancy Pelosi's husbands that's
a good one that's a great fight that's
gonna be a great fight do you know
both guys really awkward personalities
both great Fighters awkward they're
Cooks
like they're great though they're great
they're good at what they do yeah I
don't feel they keep it real oh
shot that was a nice ride but [__]
great Fighters great Fighters man dude
he's from the 607.
so it was a gold medalist I mean it's a
whole different
it's your lip is attached literally to
your nose yeah oh he's getting lit up
so there's the the cleft lip which is
whatever that's nothing to make fun of
he has the long face that's a
conquistador like I'm telling you bring
it up chin
W syndrome pallister dose syndrome is a
rare genetic disorder characterized by
unusual facial features such as clefting
of the palate and the upper lip and the
broad flat nose oh so you didn't get
punched in the nose he's born with that
nose I think they showed it because what
happened on his mouth yeah pull the the
like same with my daughter is it your
face is different your daughter had a
cleft no no but she's got Mobius
syndrome oh okay yeah we talked about it
I'm obvious syndrome what is that it's
basically an expression so like she have
like signs of me or my wife but it's
like the kid the face is just different
uh Levi yeah for some reason I thought
Lebo is a black guy I think he said
Leroy Leroy Johnson yeah
I haven't met again
you've never you've
it's a good Learning lesson for him now
he should stay off social media for a
few weeks because they're gonna be so
mean to him because hey I learned from
your role on years of listening it's
called pause
posting ghost I said drop yeah because
the language bear there you go so he
always goes yeah post and go these whole
few good comes from a Cheeto take it
from your boy he gets a lot of [__] I
just I post I'm like I bet everyone
loves this and I just assume I assume
everybody loves me I do this I don't
read comments why would you I don't I
don't either I don't reply the aims if
you're my friend you got my number yes
if you expect you have a conversation
with me on IG you won't [__] yourself
yeah it's true bro I'm the same I've
never you called me FaceTime me all day
if you say what you're doing I say go
and suck do you think my wife wanted me
to read wanted to read all my good
reviews I said I'm not interested she
goes what do you mean they're all good
to go because if I give that power I'm
going to give the negative [__] power I
don't want to [__] hear it 100 I
don't want to hear what no you know what
you are you know you're doing good so
[__] but also whether it's good or bad
you don't need it you don't you don't
want it you're that's gonna keep going
you already have a motivation and yeah
you're good and something to get you
don't need [__] motivation for
somebody no the random person online
yeah now if they're like hey Cheeto
Corey sandahagan or morab said this I'd
like to say what or if someone's okay
brand this comic said this I'm like all
right well now you got my attention but
if it's somebody I've never met I don't
give up and they have an opinion yeah
yeah I don't and especially remember
like let's see right now we're talking
about this kid
he might get mad but it's just that's
part of the game yeah it's part of the
game I don't get mad if DC or him or
Robin said something like about what
they think I lose or what what I should
do here's an opinion but also but if he
got mad I'm like yeah I get it when I
was fighting I heard some reports said
something about me I was like oh [__]
that dude give me motivation I'm
Different I don't pay attention to yeah
nothing yeah like I mean if I really
raise if you go after my family that's
it you know when it gets personal yeah
they don't know your family so even that
for them no I get that you're just an
avatar but there's also Geico like
there's just like humankind but these
people yeah but there's lines yeah but
those are boozers but those guys with
the with the no picture in the profile
with the name that is like Carlos one
two three yeah zero followers a thousand
following and says your [__] daughter
looks like my dick you can get mad and I
I've been there yeah and I got a dog
that was born with something I just like
hey cool dude man but imagine saying
that like piece of [__] yeah but that
guy's it's like so crazy you would never
he'd be the first one he sees cheating
on the street like oh you're my favorite
man can I get a picture I like that
we'll never move out of that rent room
never get what he dreams so it's like to
me it's like it's so true no if he has a
girlfriend she flicks her being to guys
like you you know what I'm saying that's
why he's upset yeah
you can't get that's what like I don't
get mad at nobody online I just don't
give it energy even if I thought you're
my friend you give an opinion that I'm
like
even before Rogan said the whole post
and goes I was way before that it just I
was like yeah this can't be good yeah
that was like four or five years ago for
me like I was like oh that's a great
advice you know I don't even block
people anymore you hit that restrict
thing or I blocked only two people it's
just like at this point it's like people
get off on the Block yeah so I just
restrict or mute question then they
don't get anything George is today you
think they will give the fight to the
hive kid that's see that's that's the
problem with judges
this kid this kid dominated Rodriguez
dominated two rounds you never know bro
you never know an MMA especially when
the hype's on him and the judges are
probably fans of him too see that's why
I think in this fight between Izzy and
Alex Alex has to knock him out to win
because there's too much money in a in a
Trilogy I love it I love both of them I
think
aspected Champion whatever I've never
heard a guy beats It Like a Dude who
everyone thought was unbeatable at that
weight class and everyone's like oh this
guy's beam this guy beats him get even
though he just beat the guy to beat off
referring to me Sam because I'm
referring to everybody nobody but
there's a reason why we say that because
for Alex Pierre like he had I think six
fights and then gets straight jumped to
the queue fights Izzy he's the perfect
matchup for Izzy Izzy had no foes he
beat the entire division so they they
speed rushed Alex Pierre right I get it
and Ashbury didn't face any Grapplers
getting there so many fights
he does well against Izzy I'm the main
one and even Pierre talked [__] to me
about it here's my thing that's scary no
it's not done take him down here's the
thing right I can wrestle now with black
belt but here's the thing Sam's not
about that right it's his night but um
with pierra you look at the other
stylistically matchups it's gonna be
like Hamza and there couldn't be a big
com in the world
can wrestle [__] of Brunson can
wrestle uh there's a number of guys
versus Izzy right so that's my I mean I
what I'm saying is like if you study
that guy's story he's done an incredible
things like after four years I know but
like this is his thing this is what he
does striking's his thing I get both I
really like if I have to decide
here's the thing he got upset which is
amazing too for him to have six fights
and to be Izzy yeah who has who's 20-0
is it's insane all I'm saying is the
world I come from is it's mixed martial
arts it's not a kickboxing match right
and there's guys out there that know
things that will blow his [__] mind
when it hits the ground
you guys know way more than or he can
wrestles I'm just a dick joke Whitaker's
almost a month and a half but you just
here's all I know what I'm saying you're
learning rubber guards
all I'm saying is that a lot of the
stuff that you could say about Alex you
could say about Izzy nobody Izzy fought
wrestlers to get to this point right but
I'm just saying it's like I get what
you're saying listen I I did mean it
towards you I'm just saying no you
didn't no I didn't I'm just kidding I
love you the pieces I'm just saying that
it's just that this let's go bro
fight him just add it like casually but
no what I'm saying here's here's how
experience hold on Alex Pierre needs to
go to 85. I'm sorry he needs to go 205.
because Jamal Hill's The Champ you're
telling me that Alex Pierre just
stylistically against Jamal Hill is a
great fight right for sure and he's a
big dude the only reason he's fighting
at 85 right now is because Izzy's there
and it's this Trilogy yeah other than
that he's if Izzy's not there he jumps
into a fight so fast here's what I said
he was he was 220
there he is right there
fight Alex pierronics I will bet my
house he was [__] two I love that guy
I love him too he also [__] up his
Wing's eyes so I don't love him oh
hey good rock there we go it's Kid Rock
with a Bud Light Kid Rock's drinking Bud
Light look at that
because Trump has all the money LeBron
James has all the money their hair is
trash I know
we're [__] no I'm fine I'm cute I'm a
good looking guy first thing cheetah
says he goes dude you're [__] good
looking I didn't hear that person he
goes what are you 30. here's the thing I
talked to with Daddy he did man he
actually made a pass at me it was kind
of crazy but I got here's why I got
Pierre I want to get your take on this
you take my heart my heart that's easy I
love Izzy and is he winning I want Izzy
to win but listen here's here's the
thing Alex is a 205er he was in he
stepped in the ring at 2 20 last fight
he was 220. now hold on
Izzy is he looks skinnier than he
normally does he he's probably going to
step in there at 200 pounds you got
Piera 220 is yet at 200 now here's the
second thing I think if Izzy can stay on
the outside and win at that point him we
got it which he's done there it is but
foreign's gonna get in that mid distance
and he wants to box and he wants to do
those Dutch low kicks where he doesn't
turn you know he's just a nightmare at
that mid distance and I think I think
because
all these guys I think he's gonna
[__] remember the last fight the last
fight he had a broken hand that's
significant Pierre I mean uh Pierre had
a broken hand last fight he had herself
so you're saying pierra is a heavyweight
that identifies as a 185 correct yes
pronouns are Saturday pronouns are
Savage I think do you think Pierre is
going to start wrestle you think he's
going to shoot absolutely no no way no
no no it's not a chance I'm gonna make a
call
going to try to make try to take him
down no I doubt it'd be a bad idea why
would he bring Randy Couture into his uh
Camp though no that was totally though I
mean I took little I mean why would he
bring chocolate out because I mean
oh Chuck no he's never attempted to take
down his entire company
he's also friends with Glover takes here
there's nobody else he would stand up
he's been with Glover I know but Clover
would be the one who teaches them
wrestling not chuckling
and he teach you how to stand up no no
he wasn't for like support like the
legend okay hanging out with the
champion with Drew Glover and the big
Master Pit Master yeah so he wasn't
there as a coach I'm a nerd no he was
just chilling it's also but he's not
teaching them like takedown no yeah so
if you are depressed if Pierre loses
tonight uh my friends have better help
in this uh episode of the Cowboys fight
companions brought to you by better help
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because
we're always growing we're always
changing therapy is all about deepening
your self-awareness and understanding
because some sometimes we don't know
what we want or why we react the way we
do if our fighter loses so until we talk
through things you need a professional
that's where better help connect you
with a licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from wherever you are if you're thinking
of certain therapy give better help a
try today it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime you want for no additional
charge discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com
today to get 10 off your first month
betterhelp.com
count you want to bet on this
because if you do we should use my
friends at DraftKings UFC 285 Fight Card
finishes with an epic rematch long time
Rivals Alex Pierre who counts taken
versus Izzy arasanya I'm rocking a shirt
and you know who I'm going for I love it
yeah forget about it throw down for your
shot to win big with DraftKings
Sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the UFC new customers can bet
just five dollars on a pre-fight money
line and get 150 in bonus bets if your
fighter wins plus all customers can get
close to the Octagon excitement with the
DraftKings same game parlays combined
multiple UFC 287 bets into one sh for
one shot an even bigger payout all right
you got Izzy yeah arasania you got uh
Mazda doll big Underdog against Gilbert
Burns you got Kevin Holland coming up
against montenibio there's so many ways
to have a fun bet and make money with
DraftKings download the app right now
use code shop show new customers can bet
just five dollars on a pre-fight money
line and get one hundred and fifty
dollars in bonus back if their fighter
wins this Saturday that means tonight at
draftking Sportsbook with the code shop
show minimum age eligibility shakes and
Supply see show notes for details
DraftKings huh
that was good great read I got some
notes for you good wins dude it's a lot
more eye contact please okay
so so cheater wait who do you have easy
why because I love him yeah I love it
yeah I love him too no you bet against
him I love the guy's guy that rides
your dick my money's got to go with with
Pierre only because he's your ass
who do you want to mount you hard so
you're taking Pier just because he's a
bigger guy at the same time oh you want
to go airtight yeah I just I just
believe in being airtight I mean you
want the DP dude daddy these are
personal questions you want to go from
both ends I'm married to a woman this is
my this is my team without Spear and
Izzy if you look at the evidence and I
know Izzy's 3-0 which by all means you
should probably bet against Izzy yeah
yeah but Alex Pierce 3-0 against him so
usually would bet on that guy he's been
three times but if you look at the fight
Izzy Rock them should have finished 10
seconds left in the first round he would
have won that fight right yeah the first
round he outclassed them for those four
rounds and then you know he just fell
off the gameplay
yes I was there I wasn't in in Amazon
instead of like staying kind of like
hard he started playing a little too
busy yeah and that's that's a dangerous
game right for an experience when I
fought Brad Pickett in London he pretty
much was two up going to a third yep his
Corners say hey chill you just touch the
leg and move around I came to the third
thinking I got seven Grand in my bank
account I gotta kill this [__]
yeah but you cannot tell your corner yo
you're fighting like hey chill never
I've been I beat the share a road phone
for five rounds but really don't tell me
Focus I'm finishing don't [__] around I
think that chain brought change Rob
font's career he could too many shots
I they should stop the fight no his
Cornish or something like I like I know
I know a thousand percent me probably
will will go into to get some brain
damage apparently we just totally
telling someone like [__] you I love you
your face if I don't have a [__] Mark
on your face right stunning I mean
that's crazy
your ears are interesting it's called
the Ecuadorian Tom Cruise he can't walk
around Ecuador without just kidding he's
a hero oh dude
tomahawks raw milk raw everything are
you a raw guy I'm a [__] I'm the real
liver King you deliver Ecuador King I'm
the real one yeah because that [__] is
fake right it's all pumped with [__]
yeah so you eat raw raw raw raw dairy
raw everything everything I what is your
diet so for the most part
you eat what carbs you eat more more
like a carnivore salad with a lot of
fruit
a bunch of vegetables that's why it's
not a cardboard but like you like
Grizzly no no bread no bread no usually
I say I stay away from everything that
is processed I do sore duck break
occasionally yeah and sometimes my wife
and myself dude from the scratch and
you'll drink a little bit sometimes I
drink wine almost every day but this is
why Fighters love Cheeto he's such a
professional he's always like this
always never not in shape like Green's
in New York I've never worried about him
eating King treats pizza or whatever the
[__] it he's just always perfect I just
went to New York I saw it and I I say
cling I said we're from food the only
day I ate it was when I went out with
with my homies that they took me to
places that they're like pretty much
like holes in the world the best you
have and then but before I went to New
York I almost like prep for a week it a
little slower eat less almost like lose
a little bit so I can enjoy myself yeah
came back checked my way this morning
54. when you're done fighting are you
just gonna eat like [__] one day just be
like bam
I
like when they fight hour since I don't
have to go down to 35 I pretty much
admit crazy meat every day do you have a
plan for yourself as far as like you're
you're working on other businesses I got
I got a dream like a personal dream to
have my own coffee shop like good Juice
drink coffee I love coffee me too good
Christian good little bit is there good
Californians in Ecuador right oh we have
great [__] so I'm sure you can get it it
doesn't make one personal dream after
fighting but right now just investing a
little bit more here and they're getting
houses would you say Ecuador is a good
place to go on vacation I never think of
it it's right now it's a little bad with
the not for you Brian with the bad guys
but if you have with the oh is there a
lot of crime right now yes wings and
stuff or what well
we sent them all down there yeah we
should in Ecuador yeah
and they blame us for starting crimes
over there Edward was really safe until
like a couple years ago right now get a
little weird why
did they take him out no and he's the
Bitcoin guy too right these guys are
really in the big one 60 000 people here
right yeah I mean he was he's got like a
Superman
oh that's the picture where they're all
like yeah
he's also said that you know because
when he started arresting everybody they
went on a giant crime spree to scare him
and he goes if anything else happens
none of your guys are getting fed ever
wow and and then San Francisco goes
we're gonna do the opposite yeah that's
crazy stabbing story yeah crazy you've
seen the video oh it's so sad bro check
this out there's in El solo the the the
M13 is the Nautilus [__] gun they're
the worst hair they will [__] take
your face off and be on you while your
kids watch yeah I like the the president
all these [__] it's true no no
put three of these [__] in your
house
they're terrible criminal justice this
these Soros like uh financed uh DA's who
just don't do anything it's unbelievable
man I mean if somebody does if anybody
arrives rape do anything bad like that
your rights are gone in that second
right yeah you don't deserve them you
shoot them in the middle of the head
bear a whole put the [__] around that's
not a good person no but these these
liberal woke cities which are the major
how are they doing Metropolis
cities they go well they they have the
same advantages you guys so there's a
reason why they shot two kids or raped a
woman you need to put them back inside
and give them a better shot like you
didn't come for money no what do you
think of all that that that's what I
would say like I could go south to I
could sell in drugs like we're mid-class
we have food we got decent [__] but it's
not like I don't know my daddy dies and
I have a couple mil
and I could go south too and I decided
to do the right thing but that's what
when I see like people in power you just
be like no they're good people they
would turn [__] no no one's turning
around because those people aren't
living in that world they don't know
anybody they don't know rough people I
do see things around California I'm like
everybody's like thinking that's it
that's not it no it's not just [__]
go two miles south you go to Santa Ana
yeah I think mommy is not like that yeah
I agree uh people that's what people
don't hustle yeah other people don't
wake up [__] with a hard dick ready
to go yep I wake up with a hard dick
every day
I wake up ready to go but sometimes my
dick's like I got zombie dick I'm like
what right now
that was really uncomfortable yeah I
don't care so I can listen you want to
play so when you're walking down through
there like is the atmosphere getting you
or are you like laser focused I'm
[__] seeing red I'm thinking this is
it I'm I'm only thinking bad things
I'm better than Cheetos like what the
[__] am I doing really I was like holy
[__] what am I I'm walking into a cage
right to me that's the locker room in
the locker room like I think I'm gonna
start just spraying more and [__] go
to an office job I've never played the
moment the moment the guy in the blue
shirt goes
I say
[__] the world yeah I have a respect
time to feed the family [__] the world
but like that's my point by the way
before that you're [__] taking a
couple of the real [__]
I've never prayed so much in my life I'm
not religious you know what you know
what you know what it is I'm so honest
yo I'm so honest I know I only chime in
every now and then I page every few
months when I have a fight
I know how and pray but please forgive
me listen you know I go straight
you know I don't do this often but yeah
I mean serious now I need this you know
you know I only call when it's important
this one's a big one I don't want to
bother you too much yeah dude if you
could like to smile on me a little bit
tonight keep me alive now this fight's
interesting because they both need this
fight so it's like a fork it's like a
fork in the road for both of them yeah
30 and six he's 36 years old you know
Kevin Hollins last two in a row well I
got hauling too he has sponsor Neighbors
he could easily win though he could
easily he said dog oh but you know what
happened with him when he had that knee
injury that becomes an infection I don't
have any staff right he got something I
don't know the details but he was sick
like almost dying for a year and
remember before that he was like on a
streak he they robbed from him ataro
shot then when he came back he got KO by
Ling Zhang did yeah this guy yeah he got
knocked the [__] up but there was coming
off being in the hospital for months so
I get but people don't know that I know
that because I talked to him yeah but
I thought he kind of like give his best
run and was Rider to fight for the
battle and that happens but also I heard
he kind of find with Darren too when
Maxwell took the fight and become a
superstar I heard they called Santiago
first he was like I don't have time they
were like that's all these business
works oh you don't want it homeboy not
what you make a name yep I took fights
on four or five days notice yeah to be
where I am yeah you have to yeah and I'm
still rolling the dice today because the
discipline if you don't yeah just turned
30.
yeah Logan Paul there Mike Tyson Donald
Trump
got some real names in there it's Miami
last fight was a dog fight yeah we're
doing is everyone here like Miami I love
buying I'd stay out of Miami's husband
on my heart my heart is in Miami it's
trouble
dude I love to just go down to South
Beach and watch the Wild Things bro and
jack off I just sit in this size
how do you know I go knuckle up it's the
best one it's like it's a stranger
a Savage man there's no way this goes to
decision no it definitely is not hard
I'd like to see the odds on decisions no
kick that's exactly what you want to do
with those skinny legs when he put a new
magnet he'd chop him down before he
knocked him out so he might do the same
because similar body type
Kevin Hollins just a awkward dude to
fight
on his game he's like a real Street
Fighter you don't give a [__] remember
when he was a superhero like four times
yeah he was just fighting crime just
randomly before he was just in Waffle
Houses yeah just stopping strippers from
going off yeah that that what happened
so many times in a row that at some
point I thought like is this guy
just makes me smaller hey dude yeah just
like let me stop this like just go crazy
you guys fight yeah do you see those two
guys the two uh explain what they did
yeah dude it is the funniest we're
trying to keep on finding the kid oh I
don't have a line into it you know Jesse
on Fires doing a podcast with them so
Jesse's my line to him he's like yes why
am I find the kid I'm like yeah that'd
be fun yeah that would be great too is
this an 85 or 70. 70.
yeah Han's a big big dude he's 6'3 but
it does is good workless 170 when he
jumps 85 for fun
oh yeah that harms that fight was just a
nightmare but that oh like a 30 minute
notice yeah [__] 18 pound difference
god dog I mean you don't miss Way by
that much oh oh yeah they can't get
harms out of fight man hey nobody wants
him no
he's going 85. look at this but no the
thing I think he was going to go into
170 and I I will believe the UFC is like
dude you missed way about 10 pounds we
can give you a fire like just too much
there's too much money in the promo they
just they're like we're not gonna just
fight at 85. yeah he's huge maybe maybe
he likes to be the bigger man yeah and
that's not maybe he likes to be the
bully that's not a good sign yeah I
agree
like when the Rings are getting tough on
him
you see like all these [__] are
humans if you start listening to like
all these [__] we all take a
shirt sitting down yep he's the same
[__] you just gotta [__] bring it to
the guys yeah
yeah we get calm the hyper I mean Hamza
looks like you know but even Gilbert
Burns he didn't really entertain all the
hype and gave it his [__] best goal
Landing some big ass shots
and what what if there was a five round
there in the Apex yeah yep yeah
Gilbert's a [__] dog man he's such a
big favorite over Moss ball now I'd love
mazarov said this is his last one if he
loses even if he were to lose I'd love
to see mozzwall versus Holland
yeah but that's
I I'm with him what they say because why
giving his name away like Frankie did
Frankie gave us too much yeah just
retire yeah like what are you doing
getting killed by all of us yeah I feel
like you know what I think it is I think
massville really wants Kobe I think he
wants to fight him
wins tonight in fashion they go Kobe
that's right talk to you a couple more
about it because the storyline when he
punch him backstage I agree they know
where it goes like Kobe
I'm sorry bro is a bigger strong than
all of them everybody that's what that's
what he says remember like if this guy
beat me I return I this is what I said
Burns got [__] crazy power it's
hungry but he's you know he flexes
up marginal is a [__] tactical sniper
and he's good at everything he's older
though it's all there we give that to
birds he's older maybe he seems a little
weaker he's still a [__] dog and he's
a real [__] Street Fighter he's not
like they're like trying to play games
no he shows up and he's tactical he's
quick he's a good snap if you think
about when he's been doing since he's
14. and check this out hooker KO Burns
before yeah Grady Striker so it's not
impossible no it's only if his health is
still underneath his is his body yeah I
don't think Mars should be as big as a
dog as they're making him I'm like man
mazaro never happens feels like he looks
like a natural 55er right oh he just
looks like a natural 55 or even though
yeah he could but like but literally for
like good Grapplers couldn't take him
though I will
right now ouch yeah I think maswell's
Advantage is in the clinch people don't
realize how good mozzarella is in the
clinch with his elbows his knees he's
filthy there for Gilbert who's gonna
have to close the distance
oh is he always at this weight class oh
is that 70. I don't know
he started 55. yeah yeah because that's
when hooker
55. yeah he did yeah how does he get
down to 55 he's [__] that's my whole
thing like a lot of guys are fighting he
seems smaller though yeah his
welterweight debut was in uh was in 2014
yesterday at 55. okay yeah
but that's in New York is 55. wow
but that's the whole thing he's the same
size as my hospital that's crazy
Burns well Weight Wise but hi you'll see
Mazda I think look at the face
he had a good base too he he's come in
the pocket he can find the problem
and he's been in front of like big
[__] Usman is huge dude I'm so
old I I started when Gilbert was just
our Jujitsu coach we're like mma's like
never he's like no not for me because he
was a world champion world champion in a
ghee Savage multi-time world champion
and you don't really see it anymore he's
in love with knocking dudes out
quick but that was a blueprint to just
take him down put him out of there yeah
magnesium that's it and I love magni but
that's one thing magni struggles he has
high level
you know what magnet fights at 170. I
was I was hit high altitude Jiu Jitsu
and I was in my underwear I'd worked out
and he was there and I was looking at we
were both there in Arnold he's so much
bigger I was weighing once the time Neil
Magnum six four he was so much wait
you're telling me a world class
professional fighter was bigger than you
and he goes he goes I get down on one
side
no I go how do you get that on one seven
he goes yes I get down there for for
eight seconds eight seconds I'm down
there like there's a moment I can get
down and I was like wait me now and he's
like and he goes back up
but I think parent goes from 85 to 220.
pierce started cutting two months ago
there's pictures of him cutting weight
two months ago that's all part of it
that's how big he is and he recoveries
from it yeah well some guys are called
like that that's what he recovers are
you allowed to use IVs yes no
well what's that stipulation right leg
there's a stipulation right because
they're saying you can use a certain
amount I guess depends on the commission
though depends on the commission you
should be allowed to use IVs I think ivy
should be allowed it should be allowed
but also the testing should be not from
six to six they could I I'm a advocate
for hey you should come at 4am you
should come at 3 P.M because if they
test you only from six to six there's a
gap and there's drugs that disappearing
oh really yes 100 guys are going to
cheat that that's what Izzy said is he
leading up to this just I think
yesterday or maybe this morning was like
you solid the fight week should be with
us 24 hours a day the main event they
should be with 24 hours you guys go away
you don't know what the [__] this guy's
gonna do he's gonna use the IV he's
putting in that IV that in two hours are
gone the scientists are always two steps
ahead of the test what I heard is like
you should only get tested from what
they know exists if you're a great
[__] doctor You're Gonna Change
molecules I guess peptides all that [__]
you've got access to Russian doctors
give me some dude I want to take all
this no yeah it's here we have the best
athletes it's here I go test on Friday
twice after the fight I would test on
Monday after the fight on Wednesday
after the fight I'm like what are you
looking for yeah with yeah people find
good quality so that's what it is he
goes there's a gap there he goes and
this guy can use a IV because they can
get away with whatever they should be
with us 24. I'd be Iving regards just
get it get it because they test your arm
put it in my leg
get busted for that yeah
didn't Floyd get busted for ivian and
that was a big problem I don't remember
that one I don't remember that yeah with
it dude this is a dog look at this [__]
yeah they're throwing some wild [__]
look at that Kevin so we're in the old
school shorts such a character man he's
talking [__] how about you got a Ryan
Garcia and uh
I can't wait I can't wait Davis's skull
it looks like he's like he's a
[__] black helmet from Dark
Helmet from no you thought I'm up from a
space boss yeah
yeah Ryan's an underdog do you see Ryan
uh sparring with uh rolly uh uh what the
[__] his name he was getting tuned up
by that guy but it was only it's not
fair that is right
I don't care about that you're seeing
Ryan in a real
fighting your head like that dude ponson
Emmy was [__] rugged Man oh this
Mario take him down
I'm taking Ryan Garcia in that fight are
you upset yeah that's because you're a
boys with him yeah that's my guy I like
him dude yeah same haircut yeah
both Mexican yeah yeah
it's a tough big test for Ryan man
that's a big test but that's a big head
to be punching bro
you're not that lightweight yeah Devonte
Davis people don't realize this he's the
best knockout in boxing period right now
yeah look at his record his Knockouts
it's no he's so good it's impossible to
believe you so was what he said about
Tyson that's like
remind you of you when he was younger he
said the only thing we have in common is
a mug shot
was giving any props to the ones he
reminded me like a smaller version of me
and probably the smaller version for him
sounds like a little guy he went like
the only thing in common we got is a mug
shot holy [__] because I'm a Savage no
respect towards the elders that's not
good but javonta Davis is like a you
watch him I Swatch him sparring and
those like on camera and he's such a
dick to people people like oh thanks
he's like [__] you man I'm not gonna
he's just he's beating dude so what
about when he was a kid you could see a
video when he's like hey just lighting
kids up that dude's been fighting guys
who are so much bigger than him from day
one when I went to a Showtime to tell Mr
when they're doing the countdown show
with him they said it's the only time
they have to shut down the filming crew
because he was like oh well I'm doing my
camp in Baltimore and he's like from
Baltimore B City like the bad parts
they're saying it's like and whatever at
midnight he said I'm going on a run the
crew's like I ever come with you he's
like are you sure you want to come this
is the only time in the history of the
countdown they just shut down the
cameras because nobody felt safe they're
just running through the hood I mean
that's just a bumper so they don't [__]
with him yeah you want to have a camera
girl there with you no hell no you're
like hey you want to come to the hood
yeah yeah good luck yeah
oh Max hallway uh I think Hollow is
going to do the 70 to cater light him up
yeah have a field day
he got the [__] stranger he doesn't
look like when he taught you you know
his Papa Was a world world strongest man
yeah who's Arnold Allen he comes from
serious genetics damn
his dad's huge the World's Strongest Man
and what what weight is he fighting at
45 45 that's weird but Arnold's awesome
is mom a tiny person he cuts a lot of
ways he cuts a lot of weight but Arnold
Allen they were talking to him because
you know his dad uh said that he did
steroids and he goes it's interesting
because my dad always said don't ever do
this the reason I do is I have to and
there's horrible consequences from it so
he's like I've always been super
anti-steric because my dad we would see
him shooting needles in his ass and you
always tell him don't do this because I
can never stop doing it now let me see
that picture of him to him he's a former
strongman I don't think he was the
World's Strongest Man brother strong man
I'll get really mad about it yeah he
competed in strongman okay but don't say
the world strongly status yeah
thick yeah he's thick yeah
is that super that kid's thick too it
looks strong oh yeah he's really strong
he [__] went through Gator I know can
I get her but four of them yeah Arnold
Allen's a [__] man
he's a really nice guy yeah is he so
nice he's almost too nice yeah yeah he's
a tough one to fight man because his
ground game is great and he got but he's
not the most
and I think we'll get it twisted with
Max Holloway it's like yeah he saw him
lose to Alexander volkanovsky but if
your name's not volcanovsky he's a
[__] problem man Max is a legend
arguably the the second one could go to
Holloway the third one he looked a
little like the third one he got he got
did definitely give to vocalypse the
second one I give to Max first when we
probably get to volkanovsky right but
that second one yeah yeah that's clearly
kind of clear for months yeah third one
clear as day for volkanovsky 100.
now
oh I know Yaya Rodriguez you like hey
who do you got I again I'm a Sentimental
I got my boy
here's the thing power wise it seems
like when I squeeze him and do the same
thing Frankie did but dude throw some
crazy [__] kids that's also Young
yair when Frankie that's true that's too
much just imagine it yeah there's a
world beater dude he will [__] those
kicks this is my thing is
out out of everybody right I was like
who the [__] you know at 45 it's gonna
be tougher let me ask you this isn't it
true that the folk when he fights you
here it's hard to find a sparring
partner to mimic someone like yair so
you're gonna see something that you
haven't seen before is that that's true
because you don't have you don't have a
nobody fights last stake on the world
champion guy that was gonna no because I
just attack on the guy one kick like
that
no he has no fear but then also his
submissions like just listen or me
Ortega is my guy but Ortega got
submitted man the reason why his
shoulder popped out was no submissions
yeah so something affect that yeah 100
so when somebody punching the door you
go to sleep he said same thing how if I
twist your arms oh bad yeah that was a
straight there we go it finally ended
Kevin Hall needed that one he said no
but for yair Rodriguez like to submit
Brian Ortega dude you're talking about
tip of the spirit Jiu Jitsu man like
just juicers and he's gonna be down
there with vulcanovsky there's Trump is
he gonna say what's up the trunk oh he's
talking to Trump there's kid back there
yeah
he don't shake Trump's hand I know
that's a mistake he might die in couple
hours
sorry guys you probably didn't want that
picture to be taken for you know I'll
probably guess you think Trump gets
cheered as he get booed yeah the UFC
event Miami
the Republican is [__] out there huh
yeah
uh I want to see the replay he's
completely who gets a bigger chair
DeSantis or Trump out there
I don't know why Trump's going out to
Santa we have to that's his competition
yeah but that's his only company Trump
is so far out in the head oh he went
down well but also DeSantis hasn't done
his first campaign stop that good
stoppage
that technique is not
nobody teaches this technique yeah he's
just jumping in like like both feet off
the ground that's Roy Jones
Jr that's a great stuff when your head
goes Facebook bad you're done good stop
look at him he got right back up and now
I wonder what he said to Trump
they probably have it on YouTube so
I don't think he said [__] to Trump
though I think he was talking to Dana
nah Trump was the way he was looking it
was he was listening to something
oh interesting
drum's like I don't give a [__] yeah I
have 34. great jobs
I come buy a new hand yeah yeah Trump's
like try dealing with the pressure I'm
under yeah 34 fellas [__]
falsifying business records but isn't
that like pay the hooker Kevin Holmes
like I I fought with a broken hand he's
like I [__] Stormy Daniels yeah okay
yeah I deserve 50k allegedly allegedly
excuse me no he definitely yeah yeah
right right you didn't give her the hush
no she probably I'd be lying about
inside no he gave her the investigation
I thought Michael Cohen gave the hutch
well through Trump right like he paid my
Cohen because he wanted to you know yeah
I love that Michael Cohen gets arrested
goes to jail and he gets a show on
Sirius radio it's so hilarious bro I'm
like oh not that Michael Cohen it's him
you got a show on series
that's wild
oh [__] oh damn that's a weird you hurt
his foot right there yeah that was that
weird kid
sidekick's a [__]
oh we got uh Adrian Yanez Rob font next
my boy too he's a sniper yeah
man and he's really good at
pulling and throwing yeah damn look at
that he's like you throw one he threw
two yeah high volume he's a Savage like
the only argument there I have a buddy
who picked uh Rob font I was like I get
it because if you look at Adrian Yana's
record you're like yeah he doesn't
really beat anybody good but he's been
starching he's been starching everybody
at the at the lower level this is the
time that's gonna either blow up or go
that's what you're betting on I think he
might win I think based on the layoff
yes but everything fun is a big
[__] phone is the biggest guy I
ever [__] I also think of your fight
with font changed fonts trajectory like
his career path he took part of his
other way for sure it's like the JDS
eBay fight like those just it's too much
dude it wasn't punches to his face he'll
kick to the face when I kick him with
the hill more than once I felt pushing
everything even an answer was like it
didn't feel cool don't I was like oh
[__] that why just because of dude
you're doing damage you go oh dude have
you ever seen that fight it's so brutal
like and I
they did a whole thing on you and I
watched it and I didn't know I knew you
were like you know a contender and stuff
but it was so interesting to me
[__] eyes the great look at his shirt
of course he has that shirt
now Theo's there I guarantee they're
going to show Theon execution yeah
that's Zach Brown
yeah
great music you you just epitomized a
fighter like you epitomized everything
about it it was like it was like you
were a chiseled song a [__] War
[__] yeah it was just PBS yes yeah
yeah are you reading a script right now
what is this audible I wrote some [__]
on my hand and uh it's the Brian
Callison those are red violets
yeah why do you get so serious
dog yeah
dear dear you can see your camel toe
right now shut up dude I wore my special
jeans for Cheeto they look great thanks
buddy see I I think Rob and I understand
each other Adrian Yana goes the decision
but I think majority decision agent
Giannis I like I want to see two ways
either the two Snappy from Janice will
get him out of freedom and he's gonna
kick his ass and the way I butter his
face probably we'll get it we'll get a
better faster sir I think the difference
is you would like you hit so hard you
know what I'm saying so when you hit you
can tell like guys like oh like you can
say like oh all right we're not gonna
play that game like you can't go tit for
tap with Cheeto like yes you know what
I'm saying like yeah some guys you can
you can exchange a little bit in this
case I say I say fun got heavy fun hands
you know he's like a heavy hitter he's
answering [__] huge his glove is
bigger than my glove but when I was
like in the cage I was like telling my
mind oh he's big he's [__] big don't
get hit early big boy
the only thing is like
Giannis is really quite quick and it's
not but when he fought Debbie Grand
which I fought twice yeah I thought the
fight David Graham won the fight I don't
understand and that's that's the that
was probably his hardest fight yet I'd
say all the guys he fought I agree but I
think with the Adrian Jana's well when
especially when it comes to Rob Rob font
you know exactly what you're gonna get
the United States
black and white you know it's [__]
good and if you play that game or you
get [__] up but you know exactly where
again with Rob font Adriana he's a
little younger a little quicker probably
has a little more tools in the yeah
nope is take the difference having get
into the test yet that's a big one for
agents this is a crazy fight
um this is a crazy fight
Darius oh my God this is crazy
Cheeto much just dare you she's a SoCal
guy have you trained with it much not at
all what what's his name yeah he's the
nicest guy ever who's Darius is it just
he's so unorthodox no he's on Earth no I
mean he's really good at kickboxing and
he's a black man he's getting his ass
kicked bite down his mouth
has the little Lord on his side I was
gonna say like when I was praying the
Lord was like get out of here when he
prays Lord's like I'm gonna take this
call oh yeah he's fighting the father
it goes Tim Tebow Darius and then I'm
somewhere down here
when Jesus Christ first yes die for say
that yeah so Jesus is like I got you my
God yeah Jesus is like I got you damn
that's a great card well you know the
Quran the Quran is Jesus more than the
Bible
Islam
I mean it was the Hillary Clinton
Muhammad had was was given Revelations
who's behind it look at Sam's fate look
at Sam's Sinister face the core on the
central religious text of Islam contains
reference to more than 50 people event
also found the Bible Abraham well the
story still in each book are generally
comparable there are also some notable
well Islam and Judaism pray to the same
God yes no we want to know how many
times Jesus the radical notion in Islam
engine
who mentioned Jesus more the Bible of
the Quran
I think it was the Bible above them by
the way big fan of uh the Bible's about
Jesus Muslims
Jesus is the most mentioned person in
the Quran 187 times in Quran yeah
because the quran's mostly a I know this
but well no you don't know no I do you
literally don't know more than than the
old the New Testament but I'm but that's
what I was saying it's not mentioned
more but but it's mostly it's mostly
actually a rebuttal it's mostly takes
the old the new 18 if he's mentioned 187
times in the Quran how many say how many
times did Jesus mention in the Bible I
might be with Brian on this it might be
more you might be of course you've
already looked at the thing it's okay
let's see
so it's 187 the Quran
700 times okay I don't get it I don't
know if that makes sense I mean one's
about him the other he's uh no but but
so it's heretical to say that that Jesus
was God to the to Muslims and Jews
because the idea that he was he was a
prophet and a great prophet why man I
heard that but no but I mean you just
you probably heard he was mentioned a
bunch like curios
chicks body count Sam check with me
about religion
this guy this guy did you go take a pee
I sit down he he doesn't well that's
like saying Martin Luther King's
mentioned more in the Malcolm X
autobiography
of the book about him not he's really
not he was way off am I right no I
wasn't way off dude how come the first
time you went inside even on our podcast
Old school camera
I dig it man it's an old school camera
bro you know the amount of good footage
I have from because I mean places other
people can go yeah I've got some sick
[__] people with that camera in the
new uh you get him uh I just got a
detail oh you emailed yourself oh that's
where I got but this is from this is
from DuckDuckGo by the way I didn't go
to DuckDuckGo damn well that's where you
want to go chase
by the way I'm so far I'm up on my uh
parlay uh yeah I'm I'm oh no I'm the
[__] no we picked do you have Rosa
Junior in there I had a different parlor
play with him I don't pick guys in my
weight class and I lost with positive
yeah it's all good people he's a buddy I
had Kevin Holland I think most people
lost on Rosa although I would assume the
hardcores out there might have picked
the other guy because that was not an
easy fight for him so who do you have
here Adrian John is that's my guy but
this is a tough test for him he's he
hasn't fought anybody at this caliber
Rob font is a [__] but I do have
uh Jana's winning via this is good I
think he's gonna pull it off
and I think he he's like he's being
Progressive looking good because she's
the right way too yeah he came up not
too much too soon so good test for him
uh after this after the races or you
beat Rob fun you know that's better than
anybody you beat Rob fun you're with the
big boys he took number seven right
there yeah you take the number seven
you're fighting the big boys then that's
what I did with Frankie that was the
fight that put me up there he was number
seven I become number seven damn dude
Heist knockout rate in UFC band 20
history damn
you're right you're number three right
now right
five I was three three lots of course
three with marabs two season one oh he's
one now and that's it but I don't get it
check this out yeah O'Malley was
whatever he was he's number one number
one yeah because number one yes then
John came to second or third
mirab beats him and becomes number one
how'd that work you don't be number one
in it maybe it was the same [__] yeah I
agree I mean how how you if the guy that
was number one is not number one and you
beat him
yeah it is the thing about the people
that do the rankings like there's no
science to it right it's a lot of
favoritism and then how do you feel
about marab saying he will not fight his
training partner Al Jermaine I mean
don't give him fight in the top five
what's the point to fight him if you're
not getting nothing out of it it's like
you you're fighting Peter yawn change
cam no it's gonna happen yeah and then
my only thing with that and mean Shane
Carver the same thing there if I were to
beat nog then I'll get Lesnar there's a
path for me to get the Top Shot and
Shane was like we're fighting dude like
that changes your life like you're my
brother but if I'm in The Trial fight
you're in the top fight that changes our
life man like I love you but I love my
kids more I'm like me too so we both
agreed like no hard feelings but if we
if we get offered to fight for a title
we're fine it sounds your friend you
said don't take anything take nothing I
say personally that's all you said yep
and there he has feelings hurt but yeah
it's kind of like the moment you guys
get in the top 15 it's almost like
somebody got a bail especially if
they're good like if you know the guy's
good he's like gonna fight fight win
streak he's like hey man you know how
this story ends dude if he keeps winning
like for for so for marab it's like hey
I'm sure you and alja are close you know
after you retire in five years you're
probably not gonna be talking to him but
you're gonna have that [__] world
title sitting on your shelf and you have
money in the bank and honestly
probably all you get more advantage of
having my rappers are turning party to
get what he's at right now I agree
is that his dad no no I think it's just
the guests walk out I guess uh how do
you think that's Adriana's Dad yeah no
that's uh well I think it is oh no he's
coaching us away no he's that pass away
too yeah that thing happens yeah [__]
up
is not fighting like the Klitschko
brothers promised their mom on that they
would never fight those are brothers
Brothers yeah we just met five years ago
we're training Partners bro and you're
in the way of me getting myself
feeding my family dude if I was making
money I'd fight you
angry
[Applause]
you call me a cuck and I hate when
people tell me
why I'm good for now okay great
keep drinking come on Who wants someone
okay we're busy later this is good this
is a 2015. this is a beautiful Bordeaux
guys I tried it earlier it's Earth Day
oh it's a beautiful one try that one guy
I can't mix that with a man's drink
right
I only do it well but no for health
reasons he just does it till expansively
he does it so he stays if I'm drinking
like that
tonight you know what I'm saying
yeah
babe I'll be a little late tonight yeah
be late yeah if you listen this don't
expect me to yeah
do you get a blackout never never you go
hard drinking uh when I'm on the road
I'm doing a show on Thursday Friday I'll
finish two bottles in a weekend of tiger
thick like I'll have
four double doubles
every night
but I never get like I always you're a
big boy yeah I never wake up like drunk
where do you weigh now right I was 270
two weeks ago damn bro yeah I know you
could rape us yeah yeah
because Brian would submit no Brian be
the last it's too easy
try to kiss you yeah Brian would
probably hold you guys down for me maybe
a good little sense yeah there he is oh
nothing dude we're talking who'd be the
easiest way
okay
we got the little cookie yeah I got a
little bit whoa yeah Rob font hits like
a Mac Truck and it's fun yeah his
fundamentals are fantastic
you're right dude his hands are oh he's
Landing early there he's rushing in
though
for Rob too you got to feel a little
disrespected like what [__] like you're
giving me this young Lion Man very much
so it's kind of like you know with the
UFC's like hey it's kind of [__] or get
off the pot time like here's Adrian
Giannis we want him to take your spot
pretty much yeah pretty much that's the
name of the game oh great punch right
there for you it's like when you've been
a starting quarterback for 10 years and
they drafted somebody on the first round
you're like what the [__] like business
dude it's so red ruthless yeah it is I
threw it to this game both land good
there
already
yeah Adriana's just a little too quick
and sees the shots
nice great elbow by uh fun a good idea
didn't land though
the agents too super interesting because
you know
like Revolution
it's more like Mexico Revolution
yeah well that's all the the scar tissue
right yeah right there look at that it's
already big Sam but it is a Russian
Pakistanian flux coming in like there's
there's a ton of monsters
um you got you know taking some shots
already a number of straight shots the
oh it's not good if Rob font shoot in
the first round
God his hands are so big but yeah it's
all he can see now he's trying hands
he's giantism in his hands check this
out they're they're only throwing
there's no one right there right now
thank you because that would change the
way that things go
or I think if Jana's uh attempted to
take down it would help him out right
now he's fainting to it when you when
you shoot when you kick to the to the
leg like the calf are you turning your
hips over or do you just I'm seeing a
soccer soccer ball oh hardness icon
really I don't even thinking not much
stick I'm just [__] you just kind of
getting I'm like thinking if I if I
break my leg kicking you I don't give a
[__] Rob Landon cheetah oh right there
he's landed a few yeah oh
see what what Adrian can't
play this oh he can't play
with Rob he hits too hard but remember
when I say point for a punch throw up
throw a coffee
oh my God
I like that that's a great comeback
story I'm a hobby for that guy yeah good
for Rob geez that old scallywag pulled
it off they're trying to replace the old
man
I said [__] you hey Jesus damage
boy that was Rock 'em sock'em robots
daddy now Johnny's got two balls here
yeah yeah and you don't have to get
balls you chew especially gets a bad
dude he's not gonna be overwhelmed with
your tricks and getting trying to press
the action
yeah I agree yeah listen I'm the biggest
Adrian honest fan play the tape out okay
that's your career let's judge it right
now subscribe to you by sweet thick
sweat from your nuts look at that
uppercut right the outbreaker was
beautiful no one saw that another one
look at the legs
but you look at Rob it's just
and then
he's cool here and then this doesn't
help right now right but look his eyes
that's a good stoppage uh the ref is the
ref is right there the ref is smart this
is his career that uppercut adjustment
if that leprecha would land it would
have protected
like at that point when people say you
get caught you didn't get caught no
you're a step below in level good stuff
that's the name of it you think it was
short good shot too soon no not I'm
looking at the last part I thought
you know him we know him he's so cool
with us but it's his career you want to
keep his career that that [__] you're
right you get only so many of those
raging too he's young so he'll be okay
but it's like man you took too many
chances against a vet who hits like a
[__] Mac Truck they just have a kid
so good for them yeah
he
dude it's offensive okay
well you never saw the fight right [__]
come on give him give him my mind you
know what I mean it was so bad man
he gets kind of like too mad you just
take it just like just you keep
complaining about it yeah it's not it's
not uh the ref's fault that you decide
to play that gameplay dude you can size
your dick in there bro yeah yeah you
checked really fast huge win for Rob
font because that young line was common
how long is Rob oh 20 and six God that's
a lot that's a career even if I'm
forever be damn yeah
and like perennial top guy too he's been
okay that's Arnold Allen's dad that's
like Chucky just grew up and got serious
that is the craziest look I've ever seen
he's like I don't want to fight it I'm
not gonna kill people
wait is he the gatekeeper because there
was a gatekeeper I think he passed away
but he's the guy his literally his job
was to block the gate by the way the one
in between rounds these spring it's a
gnarly [__] job yeah they jump no bro
they jump the cage pull that thing they
pull that like they let you in metal
yeah it feels so Gladiator because you
stay pull this metal rod and then when
they close King you're all oh my God
this guy yeah they call him the
gatekeeper and he literally had like
merch
it's like that comic that opens up for
you on the road he's like you mind if I
sell Merchants oh that's the worst go
ahead I always say yes
I bet you you just get abused they must
like you must go up two hours into your
show yeah I am uh they take advantage of
B like hey do you mind if we take 50
okay I would say dude what if we split
the door I mean we're all doing the show
yeah we're here too you know that would
be me that would and then still me and
it's you are the nicest guy well I just
I just
can I sell merch like absolutely go
ahead have fun never come off stage and
the features set up in a sweet spot you
gotta work around yeah I'm like you're
testing me bro yeah test me bro you're
also selling seeds your boy Cole Hauser
oh Yellowstone I love him
OH police disrespected he's super
disrespected disrespected I love Bella
but it's hard to respect someone look at
it it's kid Dynamite
100 percent
dude there's Bosa behind them and oh
that's uh that was Joe burrow dude I
didn't even show Joe Pearl Joe Burrows
better than Odell what are we doing here
that's it look at bone nickel right
there you got the whole group how do you
know they must be saving jokes
and also bosses back there
white people wear sunglasses indoors
either Larry Davidson yeah either I'm
okay with those Larry David said if you
wear sunglasses inside you're either an
[__] or blind it's only there's only
two ways oh those are great you're good
these are the ones that change
and if you want to make money listen
this UFC 87 card is packed all right
long time Rivals Alex Vera and Izzy
adesanya are facing off soon it's the
next time I'm laughing about my glasses
oh dude you look fine dude
you don't look crazy at all you look
like the crazy uh crawfish off shark's
tail who's like can I be your financial
advisor speaking of Finance
dude you gotta do with DraftKings I want
to watch sports yeah dude DraftKings
official Sports by partner of the UFC
new customers coming back just five
dollars on a pre-flight moneyline and
get 150 in bonus bets if your fighter
wins plus all customers can get close to
the hot gun excitement with the
DraftKings same game parlay it's combine
multiple UFC 287 bets in 2-1 for a shot
at even bigger payout you have the
co-main event Main Event you get there's
still time to place your bet parlay
Mazda doll and uh Izzy that's what I
would do although that's a pretty big
stretch because uh Gilbert Burns a
pretty big favorite but either way bet
on the co-main event Main Event download
the app right now use code shop show new
customers combat just five dollars on a
pre-fight money line and get 150 in
bonus bets if your fighter wins this
Saturday at draftking Sportsbook with
the coach shop show minimum age
eligibility streaks and Supply see show
notes for details dude wow bring up that
[__] crab from sharks and I want to
be your financial advisor
that's crazy guys bring them up for more
the crowd from shark's Tale
he's the crazy crab who's like a flat
earther
this guy yeah no no no that's I don't
know what that is go to the one on the
top left that's him
he goes I want to be your financial
advisor he's all crazy he's like a
conspiracy grab oh he is yeah well you
might like him I don't know we might
have some stuff to talk about Sam's eyes
remind me he's so good at that he's so
good at coming up with I'm getting hey
if you're out there and you do lasiks
you want a shout out uh hit me up I've
been bullied into it
oh two hours later still crooked it's a
problem
that's not getting better it's not
getting better it's getting worse it's
not correcting itself man it's not
correcting itself
I don't care bro I'm not pretty what do
I care
because I'm a crazy person this just
adds to it oh wait you said your mom
called did your mom called you today you
said yeah what'd you say my mom said my
mom and my brother used to think I was a
really crazy person my mom had like a
conversation with me she's like people
in town are talking okay you need to
stop I'm like Mom but I'm trying to save
Humanity right well today she calls me
up some person she's walking by was
listening to my show and she calls me up
on the phone and I'm talking to my fans
Sammy we got a guy here says he knows
you yeah for the first time ever my mom
doesn't think I'm a crazy person hey
imagine I was a [__] gangster I was
walking down south or uh Venice Beach
with my dad and people would come up to
my dad's like how do you know him I'm
like Dad are you gonna have to every
time somebody asks take picture yeah
celebrity dead and by the way if anyone
does gold teeth too I'm looking for gold
teeth oh you want all front look at look
at Cheetos
one I got you my my dentist
let me see the gold I'm getting four
more where are you getting the four out
the four bottom
oh he did no you're fine dude I'm just
joking around I'll be your financial
advisor I'm going through some [__]
right now
that's my real deal no those are real oh
[__] you got real gold hey I'm gonna get
real gold dog huh what happened do you
get lose your teeth no it's luxury no
you look sweet dude yeah it looks cool
it's luxury yeah hey did uh in your
mouth hey how did that how did you get
set up with cartoon for the tats he did
your whole back piece he's in my whole
box so you know cartoons like I don't
know seven year waiting list no really
the tattoo artist let me see he no he's
the most he has his own commercial for
[__] money
that's cartoon look at that [__] dude
damn bro dude you have to get my name on
your bag that's crazy
here
[Laughter]
dude
love it
how'd you get him with uh [__]
cartoons I was he's uh he does
collaboration with the the people from
Roca so like after a couple of fights I
saw him in the office and I just
approached him like yo you know who he
was obviously yeah when a little kid
yeah me too I'm like yo tattoo me I kind
of like who you are and I just a smart
student smarter go to his assistant and
just [__] blew him up everywhere with
y'all give him my appointment give him
an appointment I know we're cool oh
that's great now I can get at any time
and how long were you with him three
sessions
[__] awful now dude did we get the
homie hook up because he is not cheap I
don't because Travis Barker who's my boy
he's tattooed by him he's tattooed by
him another dude at the same time yeah
yeah he's great just to knock it all out
it was his full body
but they have similar Styles yeah yeah
they didn't know what are they doing
yeah just cartoon like uh taught that
guy so they have similar advice do you
like Ink Master
do you ever watch that show no it's the
only brain rot show that I love really
because I just love tattoos yeah
I have a couple yeah where I have a here
here here here uh let me get the Trump
one on your back no I don't have a
trumpet
well this this last week when I was in a
year ago I was trying to get my hair
tattoo to the top dude when you posted
that head tattooed in the back I was
like how that has to [__] hurt
cheetah bro oh that happened to her
gnarly and they went for the top which
is worse and we just we just feel it at
the right times I was like
next time I was gonna [__] with you
you're gonna do the you're gonna do
you're gonna do Jason Ellis style like
you can go up here yeah Ellison you know
the whole time I'm gonna do her line I
really you don't go to the face when I
see people tattoos in the face I'm like
you're a [__] cooking yeah I mean
I get it everything is a flex right but
yeah your [__] face come on I know I
know you take pictures with your kids I
think I think faces yeah that'd be sick
I'm gonna do her language
do you know shop helped me give my name
my kids keep it keep it clean man oh
tomorrow yeah we're at The Comedy Store
we're at the ice house
we're at the ice house having a real
debate on the name yeah remember you and
I'm like I want to name them ghost and
ninja you're like that's pretty cool
yeah that's all it took yeah how am I
making this walk one more time that's
his home that's his hometown too that's
everything you gotta remember is miles
at all is Mr 305. Miami you know the
only thing that was crazy you got in two
different celtications there's a lot of
energy to waste yeah I didn't like that
was the come on save it save it oh I
know because after ways he was going
crazy with somebody in the street yep I
mean that wasn't a fighter who was that
apparently it is that the guy from The
Matrix who's that guy behind the giant
black guy yeah he's the starting tight
end I think for the Bengals is he yeah
oh Brian's so turned on
why it's horny what what was my throw
try
but apparently on the street Jorge was
talking to Kevin Holland again so they
had a beef yeah I think the guy coming
out was like a manager something with
Kevin Hollins man yeah so it's not a
random guy on the street not with you
that's a lot of energy man but again for
Maslow he's the one guy I don't worry
about too much
but that's the thing like people
sometimes online
talk [__] and they think when you guys
saw each other in the street it's gonna
be like hey what's up dude no this isn't
online I don't I don't [__] like that
like I don't ever talk [__] if I'm not
willing to fight if I see the only guy
who I talk so much [__] because I was
trying to get a fight with Brock Lesnar
I talk so much [__] to him online and in
interviews and then I was fighting his
uh training partner uh uh Chris toucher
who's like 21 and at the press
conference they were giving me an award
for something and Brock Lesnar is there
I looked at my coach I'm like dude and
at least or bowling who's a little
fireplace you got to come up there with
me I talked so much [__] Brock's tried
pulling my [__] head off he's like
you think I'm like just be close to the
stage I get up there I go what's up
Brock I was like ready to do something
he's like what's up brother I'm such a
fan I dude I get it I don't take any
offense man it sells tickets I can't
tell you how much I appreciate you you
come from football I came from football
gives me this big hug I'm like holy [__]
you're the coolest guy ever yeah what
was this years ago wow that's cool
[Laughter]
first the Brock Lesnar is so big
he's probably worse than a street
fighter than the actual cage oh because
of the concrete yeah I'll pick you up
like Donkey Kong yeah yeah
did he saw red now he's on [__]
everything
he's [__] it's a lobster and why not
giant Lobster yeah and now that the WWE
and UFC's merging you know he could
easily get a fight with Jon Jones and
Jones said that's the one fight he wants
that's banking [__] kind of [__] up
right he should keep taking the dealer
shut the [__] up see he but Francis I
think can come back
I don't think UFC wants him that's the
UFC you don't understand Dana once his
mind is set trust me he does not accept
apology no no no no no no no no and the
deal wasn't bad dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
if Francis gets the Wilder fight or Fury
fight then it makes sense you make 40
mil but if you don't get those fights
and you're fighting pfl or Bellator boy
did you [__] up because now you tell me
Francis Gonna Be Your World Heavyweight
Champion and also do WWE with his
physique you could him and Brock Lesnar
for Wrestlemania and make all the
[__] money on that leather [__]
underwear oh dude I'm so hungry grades
no to what some [__] color like
yellow in the chest like [__] African
[__] well I paid to watch this [__]
the new Kamala it just hitting his tits
yeah dude that's what I'm talking about
bro see what bird Knuckles say he said
he's too expensive he goes it's
unrealistic yeah
they're like really he should take the
deal fire Jones
fight zero again
I agree man you see could go to Africa
he didn't get to a name that he could
but uh and then also for retirement go
[__] play grab us in WWE wrestle
Brock Lesnar at WrestleMania half
[__] Undertaker do whatever the
people's elbow or whatever the [__] they
call it and make money fake fighting
dude yeah like yeah with those hits dude
no the real hit oh I'm not disrespecting
WWE that is some real [__] you can die
in this here it goes yeah you [__]
don't clip on that [__] yeah he's a
sketchy but in the locker you're not
[__] in your pants you don't know how
it's gonna go yeah guys but yeah he
[__] I think he [__] up me too but
even less unless the fury water fight
comes to fruition then I'm like oh you
made the right choice that's the only
caveat if that doesn't work where's it
at I mean I I thought the uh well Wilder
thing was set well we haven't heard
anything yet so the wild thing's not set
and then Fury and usick they usick was
like No Deal so then there's potential
for socks man but it seems like I'd love
to be cold he's going nowhere well
that's a what and that's what uh I think
Dana said and the uh Scott Coker was
like hey man you need to do something
because it's cooling off now the doctors
are like okay we'll give you the chance
you're not Conor McGregor I agree like
who's really watching you no they're
gonna look at his pay-per-view buys him
like well you're not to your point
they're like you're not Conor dude and
you don't have the UFC marketing machine
behind you like and it's all on us to
sell it you're not getting 40 mil like
Conor gets or whatever you don't you
don't think
dinner let's you don't think Daniel lets
him down back
and especially our friends was like I'm
doing this for Fighters rights and pay
and Daniel's like oh you want to do that
well we're worth 12 billion right we're
worth 12 billion without you yeah and we
just made a deal with WWE they don't
need the UFC just like the NFL doesn't
need anybody check this out nobody
yes every weekend you have something new
to talk right you wouldn't you want to
this weekend saying Ross is going to
kick us he lost by Monday no one [__]
knows
nobody in Ghana we're already people
aren't I mean UFC is a brand they're the
NFL is a brand nobody's bigger than the
brand I want to say something that's
going to sound disrespectful uh martial
doesn't look like he's in the best shape
that he I disagree I think he looks
better than I expected well he's I'm a
little bit with Brian on this I love him
he's awesome he's having more lean
before that's all I'm saying maybe
because he's fighting at seven that's
all I'm saying
native 70. I know he looked like
I always whenever a guy goes if I lose
my last one it's like well and trust me
I know mozilla's business outside he's
crushing crushing with his tequila his
promotional stuff and comedy and
fighting like he's crushed he has so
much to do so when I hear this might be
my last one I'm like man Gilbert Gilbert
Burns wants to be world champion Mazda
doll rich and famous it's just a
basically when he fought Usman Usman
hurt him with the jab pretty much knock
him out with the job yeah that's that's
my only reason to be like even in out of
just hard might as well is still having
a chance in the Dragon
who is that
the girl had a crown on yep
I bet notion in it I bet no Shenanigans
are going on after the fights in Miami
zero I bet guys yeah back to the hotel
it's Easter Tomorrow there's no absence
yep there's no no bodies in Miami
striking is is on a higher level I think
no he's a high level he's just
here we go here we go right
[Music]
I think girl is going to shoot right
away you're gonna see some uppercuts
from mozzarella that's what I'm saying I
said it yeah Maslow's been there too
long Mazda also is like this ain't going
three rounds I'm gonna give you my best
shot early on and see how you handle it
I think it was gonna shoot real quick
Gilbert is a explosive athlete
might as well it's got a high-fight IQ
though yeah and I like Gilbert I'm his
clothes I'm just close to Maxwell yeah
and uh Gilbert's here the power in that
afro Dude that [__] yeah
what was that guy from uh Enter the
Dragon
oh the Bruce Leroy Leroy Jones yeah
Leroy Jones this was my favorite yeah
that hurt is great not gonna lie yeah
his hair is frothy man
I'm not a big cornrows guy anymore I
mean I feel like we've seen it I am I
did it once
I really miss it I I would love to have
but I don't have the patient to let it
grow I heard it hurts too when you get
cornrows not really annoying he's
annoying yeah all I want is cornrows
I swear to God I love it when I look in
the mirror it's like [__] you look sweet
but then I'm like I don't have the
patient to let it grow yeah look out
look out there you go baby come on man
yeah I do yeah baby see who doesn't want
to [__] that
you look sweet you really do I shave my
head this morning because you look like
a guy right out of a guy Richie film
right he does yeah that's a good thing
MS-13 accountant right there
yeah like you're above doing the Dirty
Work yeah a little smarter that was you
see what Gilbert did there just there
that's scary caught him and then he did
the smile of I'm
he went smooth
I said after every fight I shave
everything restartable wigs yeah
assume you use manscape
yes doesn't cut your balls yeah I've
been caught heavily me too like really
like a stitch oh dude where it is I'm
like I'm losing blood yeah what happened
you clip your nuts when you shave it
it's the worst it's so sketchy no I get
this Chinese [__] to shave me down oh
yeah with a razor yeah get in there bro
you open the peach up in the back I do
get the peach done yeah damn yeah dog
best shits I've ever taken now I got a
bidet dude I'm like peek I bet when you
walk in that poor trans Chinese guys
like what you know she says in your arms
she says it's better than China That's
All She said Armenian she's better than
China yo he's damaging that leg could be
worse I could be in China yeah
she's here illegally she does a great
job you see how red his leg is yeah
he's here a little bit
he is so powerful see but he's out of
control he's just
not seen it before too you know but
might as well is touching him I'm moving
a little better yeah he's light on his
feet man
so am I
I mean light my shoes I don't know how
it goes
oh oh that's bad news if he gets his
back oh you don't want Gilbert burns on
your back you don't want him on your
backs oh
everything's under control all power
from Gilbert it's there's not like a
setup there's not a snap it's just
[__] hell oh yeah if they land yeah
if it lands but a guy like that that
knows how to fight's gonna be hard to
catch like that
Kid Rock and Trump neck and neck right
now oh yeah bro America cocaine tonight
oh dude without a doubt
there's gonna be some NDA sign tonight
oh yeah foreign
for sure
oh [__] the Stormy Daniels uh search for
porn went like 300 up I looked like this
one sucked up the president yeah she was
so important back when like it meant
something more than 300 yeah when
there's real quality production like
when she was like when you were the
Outlaws did it now it's like your
secretary at work has an only fans now
your kids fourth grade teacher does it
you know he clipped him there I've seen
her work though have you seen Trump I'm
like come on bro have you seen these
chicks snitching on their snatches like
in these uh these man on Street
interviews yeah where they're like hey
what's crazy they're odd my parents in
the other room the five guys are in a
train on me you're like one girl go yeah
she goes when I was in high school I let
the entire team running training and the
guy goes
the starting five she goes uh even the
backups eleven I'm like oh my God stop
snitching on your snatch man I love it
because yeah get to it girl
first round probably yeah yeah Mazda won
their own yeah because that take them
wasn't again
kind of a little little egg on his head
that's okay
one he's got a little hematoma going a
little hematoma gone let's get that
let's get that pushed down he wouldn't
tried that Prime drink from Logan Paul
it's pretty tasty yeah it's actually
really it's pretty tasty my daughter
like I saw it in the beer but I saw the
ingredients as soon as like nothing yeah
the Sugar's not as bad as Gatorade but I
I feel you but it's pretty good it's
tasty it's like Kool-Aid but healthier
because the electrolytes in it
I love
whatever you're doing
keep doing that they were just so smart
they got that YouTube Train Early you
know what the new app is
the new apps
it's like the new Instagram because I
think that's where everyone's gonna go
once they get rid of tick tocks because
because Instagram's like child
abandoning people oh dude it's so bad
bro you're not Eddie bro so there's
Shadow band and there's Eddie Brock no
no no I'm you're Eddie brother oh yeah
dude oh yeah oh yeah I got pulled over
in the pulled over I gotta pull out of
IG for a day for call Jana Khan for
calling what
that's so stupid I was upset because I
was upset
like this is so sincere
I was upset boom Gilbert's trying to
take over now
there's only 30 seconds in the round but
no there's four minutes and 30 seconds
I'm saying there's three only three
seconds that's not fun that's not fun
huge takedown also I don't like that
closed card with that guy so we're
talking the what happened
Bruce rice burner is enforcing takedowns
more Mazda can win this fight if State
standing no doubt and that he and he
tweeted that between the rounds because
now Gilbert came out with a takedown
Gilbert was like [__] this stand up yeah
yeah he's not working yeah no it's not
working
because there's power shots might as
well I've seen a million times but
Montreal has been on the ground a
million times too so yeah but I mean
Gilbert is tip of the spirit if you stay
in the guard and lose around he won't
get submitted yeah if he turns gives us
back it's he'll get submitted
but I don't think he's going to
remember he spent a lot of time at top
team with a lot of good guys
oh yeah no doubt he's grabbing were they
both have black zillions no no never
went there yes Arena yeah and he started
as the juice Coach and he's the jitu
coach at black house that's right I'm
surprised he's keeping his guard closed
like that you don't when I got that
level if you open it he might be so it's
passing into half guards that's where
the because there's really no
submissions for him there he starts
getting a half guard side control
yeah you're not gonna get finished but
he starts passing so you're not gonna
put your feet in his hips and stuff
because he knows what well if he can
stand up but if if he lets uh Gilbert
get to like Mount and stuff you're in
serious trouble with the world so you
keep your [__] you keep your legs
closed yeah that'll be a sketchy yeah
unless he can get to the cage and CR and
crawl up the cage but right now right
now you don't want to do ring on top of
you with four minutes and a half to work
yeah but you know the referee is already
asking for work videos hold him for a
little bit especially in Miami [__] yeah
he should just keep that underhook that
he has right there on his own double on
a hook on your way
Let It Go like that for five rounds
agree that's what I'm doing if that's a
if if that's your move and the guy can't
get out it's like that's on him yeah
that's with you that's that's unfair to
stand people see Gilbert's gonna start
passing here beats and get dicey for
miles at all stand up use that cage and
stand up [__] there it is there
it is he's blocking the leg so he can't
get the leg in to get his back oh crap
he rolls look at this oh okay he's on
his back
but he's hand fighting break the hands
break the hands
is born Eagle I mean tells you around
like a [__] piece of [__] you can you
can fight anybody oh [__] who do you got
bow nickels or well that's right by the
way he's he's training with both now
yeah I love Baltimore
exactly right
he's just super early to talk about yeah
I need more of a you know even for about
how many fights his kamza have no both
nickel a lot more time in MMA like he's
at least two more fights two more in
that second one needs to be a dog like
they're announced Bo nickel's next fight
which is a tough guy but it's not like
it is
the announce Bo Nichols fight
bro nickel they should just give him
some time to figure out the Striking
Monica's gonna have two more fights and
he's then he's in the top ten easily
easily
look at that look at this good job by
Miles yeah if you can just get out of
this round and not get submitted
but it was he's breeding a little heavy
now
is that perfect afro on his face
but also the rim might be getting tired
too
nickel how to strike and nickel was
teaching him how to wrestle for sure
that's a good
that's a good exchange there he's
pulling in there look at this just stand
there right there come on
come on hands up get from Oswald get it
back to the feet oh yeah my soul looks a
little tired oh good kick
it's a great program he's a little hurry
let's make a face there or not
might be a little tired oh Jesus
10 seconds who's gonna do something here
I'm impressed with Mazda I got to be
telling I got to tell you man he's he
lost this he lost that round for sure so
it's 1-1 I think one one some going to
the third level some of those reps might
give the first round of Gilbert but I
think it's one one just takedown was
Savage yeah look at that yeah strength
boom yikes
but it's he even on that he felt pretty
good he landed well yeah he was supposed
to give up his back
that didn't really land ooh that land
for Gilbert
yeah good right hand they're in the in
the break
because the judges did the judges give
it to Mom
I want to win this round decisively oh
yeah it's 1-1 yeah that's Henry hoof
right yeah correct yeah uh Gilbert's
Corner Henry grew his hair out yeah he
kind of went hippie are you gonna go
that long I don't think that long
mine was like that when I have I'm
trying to look I'm trying to look like a
werewolf you're trying to go Lost Boys
right yeah there we go a little lost no
be my girl re-watching True Blood she's
like I like the werewolves are you gonna
do a lot of air guitar
hell yeah totally totally like Bill and
Ted's Excellent Adventures I like Ryan
Clark
was Ryan played for who the Steelers
safety
dude how bad are the Raiders off season
the Raiders have done nothing well you
have the draft coming up so we'll see
what happens let's go what pick you guys
have in the draft my Broncos suck all
the cops at least we have Sean Payton
though dude I like that kid hooker out
of Tennessee dude the quarterback people
are high on him he said he would have
been the first pick if if he didn't have
some of these injuries I guess well he
jacked up I think he got his ACL or
something but apparently they said if
that didn't happen he'd be the number
one pick
[__] uh but he's 25. but I'm like
these quarterbacks play to their 40. but
if he's 25 he's ready to go in like that
that means he doesn't need a warrant
well he's 25 coming out of college yeah
wow red shirting three times what do you
think we started late played baseball
that happens all the time Chris winky
Joel clatt did that
I like the kid from Kentucky yeah
they're like it's so interesting because
like Anthony Richardson's jacked and
everyone's like Florida he's such a
great athlete and then this it's like
all the scouts are Brian Collins just
because it's a jack black guy they're
all trying to Jack them off I'm like but
he sucks he can broad jump really far
I've never seen a quarterback have to do
that yes but but then this kid from
Kentucky's Jack too and they're like
he's a narcissist I'm like that kid from
Kentucky played with white receivers
yeah and still one game that's what I
was saying I'm like that guy's doing the
Lord's work
his running back was white in the SEC
yeah and he still won games I'm picking
that guy he played I'm the panther to
the teeth I have this Theory oh back
kick what the [__] and low kick dude
he's nothing more dude
the best pick in the draft is the the
outside linebacker for Alabama is it the
one in trouble uh no that's a kid from
Georgia he killed a person I'm the
Alabama outside linebacker the Russian
he's gonna be the next Lawrence Taylor
he's so oh really he's so [__] good
the Raiders need a cornerback oh [__] oh
[__] oh no oh you play the game there's
some good Corners though that kid from
Oregon the kid from TCU doing good if we
take that Richardson get out of the way
get out of the way it's such a Raiders
pick that's such a Raiders and that's a
Josh McDowell yeah it has written all
over it come on don't get [__]
playing games like that
this is this is this is the round yeah
this is the round it's kind of I wish it
was five right you know what I got home
I got her head I'll tell you why he's
he's landed a bunch of kicks he's
Landing punches coming on here yeah
here's the thing though remember Burns
right five miles not looking too bad
come on come on come on come on don't
get out of the way please oh oh [__]
damn it that uppercut's trouble for you
yeah it's true that uppercut wearing
roses it's too hard keep your hands up
please keep your hands up get out of the
fans yeah it's not oh
oh I'm sorry oh Jesus yeah Burns this is
where Burns starts closing and this is
not good please get out of the way get
off the fence please go there dude move
move move that's good that's it kick
that low there it is
there you go throw it answering jumping
knee come in two minutes left there it
is that's a jab right there I I still
think might as well has a chance of
winning this he's not winning this fight
run his clothes oh [__]
on mozzle though he really does he plays
this game
luck
defense
[Music]
this was a good fight you lose too so
you got to get the [__] out of there
yeah right now Muslims losing but a good
fight still a good fight good showing
yeah good showing very good showing yeah
I do think Burns won it but that's okay
especially gets this take down oh
definitely won and he's in side control
trouble one minute left world class Jiu
Jitsu and right now you have now you
give your bug you give everything else
yeah whatever happens yeah
you pull that emergency brake right now
or you could just go you know what this
has been fun I'm gonna go back into my
15 businesses
don't touch my face like that without a
warning
Master doll is a great name for tequila
it really is That's So tequila awesome
soda please
yeah it does sound nice
I like them everything else is game
bread yeah game bread promotions do you
see how much he paid Anthony Bettis and
Roy Jones Jr my God he paid those boys I
think they paid Roy Jones seven seven
hundred thousand and they paid Anthony
pass like 550 or something
uh Anthony Pettis bear knuckling with
Roy Jones is uh it was boxing don't say
bare knuckle right
hit the showers who won good for him
Anthony what you said fight yeah last
weekend
then Jeremy Stevens oh we got a Jeremy
Stevens and Aldo went to a decision wow
then Aldo called out uh Connor
they did it for boxing yeah
they're taking them won the fight
yeah Gilbert won the fight
good showing by maswell though he's just
[__] so game I I hope he's done
because we're just gonna wait around
till you not ass up you face down like
that's a great retirement fight yeah
like great retirement yeah went to
diesels with the top five guys you look
good
about to be a world champion
like at the end when it was the punches
when he was eating crack he was getting
a little hurt yeah because you look at
like Gilbert versus Leon Edwards I mean
tough fight for Leon Edwards even though
Leon's stand-up is obviously better but
as far as the takedown's going he gets
your back you're in some [__] trouble
man yeah like it's not a bad matchup
I wonder what they're gonna do with
Muhammad
him down making way more some guys just
don't have that click yeah
why why it's [__] up you just happened
sometimes first of all he's a he's he's
a hero in the Muslim world you guys have
killer you could bring in the entire
Muslim world with him but when I was
with him I was with him in Chicago every
everybody was Arabic or Muslim stopped
down they'll be you gotta realize they
go off numbers
Bahrain and places like that he's like
he's like you were not like I like him
like personally
gets zero respect love from fans and
from is that because he's like
Palestinian maybe personality he's a
little dry and then glasses hinders
doesn't help yeah yeah he's a good
analyst too like he has his
personalities
yeah he's a great story too and they're
they're talking about give him uh uh oh
is it Chevron right you know just
something you put two two guys in the
top five to kill each other for no
reason put one with the original one
with Leon yeah you know the white make
them kill each other yeah it's almost
like they don't want neither of them I
agree
shout out Jeffrey Wilson my boy Gilbert
had a shot at the title first you have
to win one more because you know beating
Mazda doll isn't going to put him higher
in the ranking unless if you knock him
out yeah yeah exactly but when a
decision over mazlo I don't think bumps
you bumps him up in the rankings oh
everyone's got an afro but you could you
could do Gilbert versus uh Muhammad
that's a fight to make it's a good fight
he's gonna call out somebody
but I you know it's all styles style
stylistically at the top you know
Muhammad Leon
Gilbert Leon is tough fight
oh his kids are so cute the shirt's
great too how much do you love your
[__] kids man
if you don't have kids who sure is that
that's Gilbert's and this is Izzy's
Brian has seven kids no three yeah three
fourteen I know 15 today 11 years old
and uh 14. look at his kids going nuts
in the back before we get this main
event this uh episode of the Cowboys
fight companion is brought to you by
engage fight gear a clothing brand
engaged has partnered with Muhammad Ali
uh to bring an exclusive collection
which pays tribute to the goat with uh
alisanya who dreams and draws
inspiration from Muhammad Ali throughout
his career so this collection draws from
that unique personally Trails of Ali and
arasania while fusing so small chin
while fusing engaged DNA on the series
of vintage style t-shirts designs so you
see this one you see Izzy Muhammad Ali
those are great yeah Sam rocking one
they got a white one that's dope I love
it yeah I love them you just always die
so when people want to give you merch
like this could be bad but these I will
rock go check them out at engaged uh
yeah it's good stuff man where do you go
where do you go no I wore a hoodie
underneath where do you go at engaged uh
yeah it's engaged fight gear engage
engage yeah hit the video for us check
out this video
it's cool and they did at that time I
didn't realize how great I was
[Applause]
[Music]
I told you all that I was the greatest
of all time
[Music]
[Laughter]
how about that audible fart that girl
special big J key with a podcast
have you watched this special no I bet
he's [__] I will challenge anybody
find me a funnier special than Big J's
new special when he's doing his crowd
work dude what
Jorge retired nice Mars man good for him
he has so much [__] going on outside the
Octagon this is exactly what he needs to
do good for him one of the best man what
a great career too and he's a guy
everyone loves because he never got his
dues he'll kind of have that salty
record then finally goes on that epic
run Darren till Ben askren you know this
nuts okay he's all mad hey the only man
to carry the BMF Bell that's right
that's a button yeah so yeah Darren till
aspirin Nate Diaz Cerrone like you look
at his list of wins
and the Steven Johnson living Maya they
were used fights that split decisions
but one of the greatest runs in history
and also a fighter that blew the [__] up
dude when he beat Darren till in
Liverpool it was in London we knocked
him out when that was supposed to be
there until his night he chaos Darren
till starches him then one of the best
knockouts fast Knockouts all-time UFC
against Ben ashgren that catapults him
is a super stardom then the rock is like
I want in this BMF belt he's there in
his tight
shirts
one of the greatest ones of all time
yeah for sure
look at him shaking Gilbert's hands I
mean are those kids too yeah there's
this girl
there's this friend that's so Miami in
in the back
his friends so Miami you'll see him pass
by with the most Miami shirt you've ever
seen in your life I love it
well the guy who plays for that oh there
he is
Theo got his camera time
Theo tweeting out right now Dana you're
too good to us 79.99 dude you're the
best Uncle D
every fight to get the broadcast
uh
these older guys are retirements good to
see yeah yo I'm going to be in Toronto
next weekend come see me yes we change
the guards yeah and also see shop in my
second show
at times
are going to be doing Sarasota uh we
don't have a date yet but sometime in
May oh there's Nick Bosa who want to
suck off both of us Joe burrow too dude
not so much not so much a couple of
handsome [__]
yeah she's a handsome man you're a bad
person
to say yes you stay on this Gino don't
get in trouble don't get in trouble with
this we're we're out she's a she's
badass sometimes she's the girl she's
100 ago
I saw Serena Williams she's amazing
at this kid's park that was that she's a
sturdy woman but bro the biggest peach
I've ever seen dude I'm a human being
I'm gonna one up yeah Sam I was in her
locker room when she was doing the Miami
open with Tim Tebow and I could not stop
staring at that time
roast yeah and she was so [__]
athletic I felt like I I felt like a 300
was walking by like like a viking was
why of all Brock Lesnar of when like
just this just Next Level athlete human
I went I get it see yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah if you have kids with that tag
she's like she's putting out D1 oh that
guy from Reddit was like she just you
know she orders his food and [__] she
puts him to bed I get it dude I [__]
get it go first moving I was like yeah
dude dude I respect him now alisonia is
fighting amazing respect too you respect
who Serena
shut up Nicholas Cage is on the screen
he had Alex oh honey on our podcast
uh and I was there you sure that wasn't
the time I was that they were there and
he was on fire and we talked about
Reddit him started yes we did are you
sure he was on yeah but he talked about
it and he talked about having uh uh
season tickets to the Redskins never
mind the guy from Colombia yeah
yeah
I don't remember him being a kid can't
Google it so I don't think so Brian Baba
I'm telling you I don't think so I'm
gonna wear a fox
um
I've always positive he was on Fireball
I'm I'm almost positive you sure you're
not thinking it was J sharp it might be
a little high yeah
I I'm almost positive here
because I would I wouldn't allow him on
our show I think he was on looks like
he'd be so boring no the guy who created
Reddit who started read it no no he was
never honest I think he did fight on the
kids I would have turned that down and I
think we spoke about might have been
maybe it wasn't in person
it might have been interesting hey did
you have a dream about this yeah there
you go could have been a dream about
could have been a dream here we go
you're crazy huh a little bit a little
bit are you guys bet on this or no we
are betting on it and uh I I love Izzy
and I feel like he's being a truck dude
I feel like a piece of [__] I don't like
betting against is he I'm just gonna say
this if Izzy loses remember he lost to a
man in a different weight class
you picked the price my hand's right
here my cold big wet hands right here I
mean I hate betting against Izzy it
doesn't matter you're gonna do it if as
he sees this no I love you and I and I'm
I'm I think you're the best champion in
many ways ever
dude I'm a cuck but I love Izzy but I
gotta do it all right you you pick you
pick you wanna what do you want to do I
don't know three grand yeah all right
I hate doing it I don't want to take
your money
but but Izzy's fighting a guy who's a
205. I know you keep saying that dude
and I want to lose three grand I want to
lose three grand Main Event time
oh
fights
oh [__]
is Rogan in a suit tonight no
he's just it's too hot in Miami for a
suit
he's wearing a black shirt
butt up yeah you have to get the tits
out probably wore it last time didn't
have it washed
oh that was so [__] close how about
Izzy showing up in that dog because he
is a bad mother
and I'll tell you what if is he looks
like he's starting to win I'm gonna
renege on my bet no you can't you never
know with me I don't have any character
Pierre was out on his feet I was saying
how about Izzy showing up in that dog
collar to the weigh-ins you know Izzy's
in the weird chip bro he wears pearls
gets French manicures yeah I get I get
my feet my toenails done yeah I've done
that before I don't like it I don't like
it because they make fun of me I don't
understand you're speaking you know
Chinese and they go oh we Godzilla big
toe I can hear him say that hurts my
feelings oh I'm sorry there's no alcohol
in this right no man okay
yeah yeah
vintage Cola Daddy you think I could
spike your drink with alcohol
no man
like but right now
50 minutes you should bought a house
here yeah in Costa Mesa nice
Mesa man [__] epic I can walk to
Newport it's like too much that's where
you live now yeah it's the best I've
been there for seven years this is God's
gun do you have an idea who you're gonna
fight next
I actually took hunter called me two
days ago Hunter Campbell the Matchmaker
B only he asked me like what you want
and I say sing like send send a paper
with a name as soon as possible
as soon as possible as soon as possible
you don't care who it is I wonder who
the hey chin bring up the rankings let's
sit around will you bring up Jet Li chin
oh that's from unleashed the closet oh
that's why he's wearing the color I
think that's why well I didn't say that
yes
he said because dogs no so in this movie
as soon as they take off the collar he
just destroys her August till March oh
you want to get in I want to get in
I mean if I'm healthy why wait I agree
my mind is in a good space I'm ready to
work so yeah you have no injuries from
the fight let me see the rankings Which
Way class Sean
I won I wouldn't be surprised if
I mean I don't know how long Ortega is
going to be out for I can see the Ortega
fight I'm I'm surprised Josh Emmett's
getting that fight he took that fight
against uh yeah no Josh Emmett just got
a fight that's oh that's too soon to
pour you he's fighting to put you I
don't like that fight I think the person
that sleeping I don't like that fight
for Josh Sherman I like to I think you
get the win I you could get the winner
of that I think you get the win no no
you're just looking wrong I'm sorry I'm
sorry yeah yeah but I will kick my asses
too big yeah they're too big but I do
think uh for Emmett I don't know why I
guess you just want to get back on track
for you so yeah Corey Rob they might do
that uh I could see you guys running
back the Sean O'Malley fight if Sean
would take it even though he's coming
off a win
Peter yawn makes the most sense that's
what I told I told her Sean is there I
told I told him I know you won't do this
fight now because it don't make sense
for you guys you guys cannot afford him
to lose to me right now
I said John it's right next to me let's
do that fight it's still a former
Champion I haven't found my rock but I'm
guessing
it's not they won't do that either no
Peter John I mean it's it almost the
fight makes itself yeah the period fight
makes it right there four versus five
yeah you already thought Rob you fought
down the Cruz
yeah I thought Sonya down yeah for
almost the whole time you follow
everybody it's crazy John's gonna be the
fight
I bet that's the main event on the fight
night or a big co-main event on
Pay-Per-View come on this cheers
Jesus the Wine's getting to you no no
he's wine drunk it's a no look no you
got a point bro we should it's bothering
me we're gonna oil this [__] chairman
why are you moving around so much
because I like I like to move your butt
later yeah yeah I'm always moving around
I'm a noisy [__] are you [__] throw
[__] around I'm like oh here comes the
dog oh look he still has that swag which
I like oh look at him
will someone get uh cheeto a uh lollipop
please and thank you they're my favorite
drinks oh really I [__] with them a lot
yeah they're nice why are they good
they're healthy for you oh these are
healthy yeah why are they healthy only
two grams of sugar okay
probiotics in you it's like a healthy
kombucha this is my favorite kombucha
ideas yeah I love those this is the only
one I fought with outside this one all
right so I can drink these okay yeah let
me have fiber
uh ear one you can get them online too
they're about to they're about to get
big
dude I want easy to win these are my
favorite I just think is he's an 85er
and he's fighting a [__] two 205er
okay thank you sorry man I get excited
and I get really easy outclassed them
last time he just needs to stick to the
game plan
you know how you get it I promise you
can't let your hair get in that mid
distance that's not good for him Perez
is too strong
he's had him on skates
I feel like Alex has to knock him out
because everyone makes more money if if
there's a third fight I'm telling you
right now Izzy's looking good too
how's his nipples looking
yeah he's dude he's in the anime he's
wearing Pearl's necklace you know he's
in the weird [__] oh dude he when it
says sexuality checks other
options
that's a big guy to talk [__] all the
above yeah easy it wasn't me yeah he was
a guy next to me it's me it's me Brian
Callan
laughs
is he Izzy looks very confident
that's the thing about Izzy if if he
wasn't coming he's a champion for a
reason Brendan well he's not a champion
okay but he was a champion for a reason
damn it
Izzy looks fired up
so am I bro
you drink of me that's that tropical
drink yeah it's [__] tasty how many
beverages are you drinking right now
right now
boy
[Music]
turned into natural wines and the ones
that we drink it's literally fermented
grapes hey is Action Bronson still on
the health kick he's still down in
weight bro we we lift weights every day
I like him he was absolutely crazy don't
[__] with the albanians bro you don't
[__] do his baklava trials 106 bucks
try uh ammunition one is good
look made of wine
just say Jew on it that one is a great
two with him on the pick that's him
actually in the this one yeah that's him
go look at him go
shh
[Music]
back bro respect it's going down he's
feeling it right now he is a big man
dude he's just you think Trump and Kid
Rock are into the fights right now
they're like God when's this [__]
thing end so we can get with these
hookers
[Laughter]
they should pay them this time yeah
I'm losing my green card by tomorrow I'm
kidding bro yeah he's not president yet
my man but he gonna make some move
yes he's a 205 dude I'm aware
it's not an 85. how [__] bad as
[__] over is oh did he get nude he's
got Mooring by the way if I had one body
I want that body that's the body for me
you want all the body I just want to be
long and rangy like a [__] giant
mantis [__] mantis just just a guy
who can be like get the [__] off dude at
56 you can get there bro you can get
there bro do all the Roy do all the trt
dude with my help
Champion I would throw long uppercuts
you got the same body type we do have
the same time yeah thank you take your
shirt off come on this guy's got a lot
of dragons on him I got I got one oh
sure okay all right all right
you look better now what they say if you
want no man's age look at his nipples
yeah
nipples those are some serious look at
your stomach bro I'm I'm proud of you
that's a nice salami that's not bad hey
now you've got some jizz gutters right
there bro calm the [__] down right now
no no no hey Hold on shut off the whole
time the whole time bro you up here to
win do not put down now let's just be
honest with a little incline bench kill
him no bro I don't put your shirt on hey
with a little incline bench
every Tuesday Thursday where's your ink
you're trying to be a gangster oh yeah
boy that's the creepiest thing I've seen
in 10 years Brian do not put that shirt
on come on okay blame the wine of the
kombucha and um
job if you keep his head off that's the
attitude I'm looking for yeah where's
your ink Brian you need some ink you're
supposed to get it years ago when fine
kid reached over 10 million listeners I
know I just didn't know what to get now
I know what I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
Cheeto Vera respect cartoon's gonna do
it
I I I bring you I'll make some calls
we'll say hey no promises we'll go he
doesn't do white people
[Laughter]
they say they're the same height will
you go to back to them they're not the
same height
or I've been saying this he could fight
a heavyweight when I was in New York
on way in day
Pereira was bigger than easium fight day
oh yeah you copy that he's mad I was
there and I was like
holy [__] oh this [__]
this is the last time I get win loser
draw this the last time you see him at
85 I guarantee after how he makes it
it's a nightmare look at him and he has
his facial expressions have you seen him
on a roller coaster they put he's on a
roller coaster same face just no emotion
throwing up going down just staring at
the camera is he is my favorite fighter
dude
his Corner man has the same hairline as
you Brian
[Laughter]
Elvis is
dude why are you doing
if you have a great beard
why are you not shaved you have a great
beer Let It Grow Big yeah you look like
a [__] Viking I think I'm gonna do it
listen to him grow the beard shave the
head dude here's the game plan
grow the beard shade the head do some
incline beds yeah I'm trying to look
like Jason Statham
hey this is you the look okay it's going
to be gray though it doesn't matter no
that's right
it's some White Walker [__]
yeah he's right look at that dude that's
it
that's it that's you right there who
doesn't want to [__] that
everybody definitely not dominant Cruz
like a Castaway shave your head that's a
crazy Castaway beard all right I'm gonna
shave my head [__] are they why big bird
looks like an experienced man yeah dude
you got wisdom wisdom and a big dick
bro I used to shave
too no I used to shave my head all the
time dude you'd look sick with a shaved
head
[Applause]
it looks so
so it'll look like a baby ostrich
yeah but you know you don't want to do
that you don't want to let it grow it
looks like no you gotta stay that's good
I like that a lot of dragons
hey man this has been a [__] on Brian
[__] podcast no dude he's outside
looks like you're crap what are you
talking about I'm throwing some bumps
I look like you're crazy
advisor I've been verbally getting
banged in the ass and up in a hot house
in a bath house this whole time dude
this is I'm nervous
you have three grand online
I want to lose a three grand for real I
want to lose it oh you guys bet three
grand yeah
I've never want to lose three grand more
I just don't see
fight a bigger
bigger I'm a giant but is he is is he
you're betting if the CH the the heart
of Izzy man I don't like it Brian
UFC wants Izzy to win so badly I wanted
you to win everybody out of this room
everyone this room wants to win but also
this is you'll never see Experia at 85
you can go 205 he's gonna fight Jamal
Hill it's a tough matchup for Hill so it
wins for everybody if Izzy wins because
he because homeboy can just jump up to
205 and become champ
now now watch the difference is Izzy
turns his hip over when he kicks he does
that Dutch [__] style where he
doesn't it's just like they uh
what improvements they've made I think
it'll be a very similar fight Bubba well
if a similar fight then is he's gonna
win
see he's not getting too close with
those [__]
Izzy is lasered focused there he is so
am I dude
I'm lazy oh yeah it's a low [__] kick
for for me please
you can't be rooting for Izzy when you
got three grand I will but I I will
notice I didn't give you a shirt I'm
just being I had to go with it put my
money I'm taking this shirt
yeah [__] you that's not cool yeah not
cool man yeah you took a Sharon bed
against him that's [__] up he's making
money
that's too emotional
oh there there you go is that jab he
does that jab like this he doesn't turn
it over he just goes like he lands some
good kicks early yeah he is
yeah why not
of course dude
yeah that's a nice quality shirt huh
you Muhammad alifa oh I love him there's
some distance here I love them oh that
look is he scoring some points with
these leg kicks oh little question mark
for you question mark
Nelly is that your ass or your mama got
reindeer those those little kicks gotta
hurt right when he just he does those
little yeah you don't want to take that
one no Pierre just hit so [__] I was
talking about his dick but dude I love
Izzy's tattoos they're so awesome
silence
[Laughter]
just comedians just everywhere
on his back
come on easy let's go
man I love Izzy's tattoos
by the way look at bears like a little
red
they're the longest level in my [__]
life oh [__]
how funny should I do man
oh nice kick to it boy look at how big
it is I haven't even felt that [__]
[Laughter]
oh you heard this is straight oh you
heard it straight yeah
okay
I don't know what to say oh
dude her hair is very tentative very
tentative in this fight yep I'll tell
you why Izzy's like I'm taking my belt
back I'm taking my belt back Alex wants
Izzy to take chances because usually
Izzy's uh
[Laughter]
by the way I'm going to tell you this
right now this is going to go for
takedowns when there's 30 seconds left I
said it
oh like the Matrix he is the Matrix come
on Izzy style Bender oh I got Izzy for
the first big punches being landed
not yet
Trump's like oh God
Trump's like God look at his tattoos
oh oh that was a big Levin
dude
Focus bro like I thought what's going on
I've laughed through half the round
oh [__]
what do you think one round is he yeah I
gotta get busy that round
I guess we got to get a little bit of
leaning towards this evening Luke 10 9
is he being aggressor leg kicks 100 good
the copy strike number 15 in the morning
um attack yeah he's pushing the pace
yeah yep because Corman looks like he's
been on fire
that's it
holy [__] he's probably like hoping they
can't come over this angle
sure enough Grandma's like whatever
that looks like that looks like him
yeah you should have done the Carlos
boots it looks like a bad lawn it looks
like a bad lawn
holy [__] looks like my neighbor's life
you know what it looks like when you put
a new sweater on a white yeah oh yeah
you pull it off it's just [__] all over
[Music]
[Laughter]
25 bro we got 20 more minutes Brandon
let's go 20 more this has got some long
flat feet
I gave that round to uh Izzy because
he's shinier
come on come on come on Izzy see it's
here
he wants that midday Ohara wants that
mid distance but is he saying you're not
coming close to you've got a kicking
distance there's been no hands
throughout oh here goes Pierre now he's
coming to life now he's hunting him down
now the Terminator is coming they're
terminated no Izzy get out of there yeah
Jesus Christ oh I don't like this I
don't like this with my money easier
playing with my money bro it's my
problem
it's not he's a 205 or I keep telling
you guys well he's really too big he's
too big he's too big when he closes
distance if I'm pure dude just go
forward like that excuse me [__] out of
everything no I know Pierce I wonder why
he pulls back he's just he can stand
there and take those shots remember Izzy
doesn't knock a lot of guys out so fast
it's like saying [__] okay in the air I
like saying [__] in here he's so big
that he can absolutely Brian is like
having chat GPT qualifying
laughs
so so General
these guys are sweating they're both
tall
they're both long Fighters
they could fight at 205 if they wanted
one has blue shorts they're both tight
shorts
all right let's go come on look at this
oh the I mean the kicks
so much but that's how good is he is
that he can hang in there but that
[__] is not a 85. oh God it's a
good enjoy Pierre right now because
you'll never see him at 85 ever I don't
know he started cutting two years ago oh
[__] that was a hard stiff job Izzy
always gets caught like I know it's
funny so everybody gets caught but Manny
he
yeah everybody's hitable oh
it's not right there Alex is rolling
with the shots there yeah he is
oh good good when he when he throws that
slow kick just but it's almost like Izzy
has to land threes and then Alex just
needs one it's the fight of his life
it's no joke I mean that ain't that
Clinton they throw the uppercut that
thing was so cool
those [__] kicks have gotta hurt
right you know
is he's Landing there no that that
Pierre does those low [__]
Dutch the kicks I can handle it's the
the hands of beer that worries me yeah
oh yeah
is he is he's working his legs yeah is
he's finding a good fight here come on
Lizzy is so focused he's so focused dude
and you better just is that a gorilla or
is that a uh a bear down there easy no
on the tattoo on his leg okay look at
this look at this come on Izzy come on
come on oh you cannot let him get that
oh he's downstairs not that boxing
distance
yeah oh let me see there you go there
you go I would imagine it's a gorilla
come on come on
take it easy take it easy
this is what my hair has to do start
cutting the ring off and just maybe it's
like a raccoon
I like when Izzy throws in combos he
just opens himself up no is he missing
with the when he's throwing multiple oh
[__]
oh there you go Izzy that's running
around everybody peep out of him but
remember has he had success like this uh
last fight he has to do this really in
the fourth and fifth because that when
he comes forward like that it's such a
dicey game for Izzy and I don't know why
it doesn't come out like that from the
start it's a dice here he goes now look
he decides you see what he decides to go
[__] goes dude imagine this at 205.
uh Avalanche
ouch nail biter hey we're in the middle
of a [__] title fight yeah
that's Apple that's Steve Jobs [__]
with us oh oh no no no no oh did he hurt
him oh
my God
ow bro
what is he pointing at
dude he's such a bad [__] he
just took his [__] he took it back too
much weight God
is
here's the thing even though even though
the series is three to one that
chapter's over you'll never see him
fight ever again you'll never see it's
over look at him
holy dead cold dude that's your brain
will hurt from that I see your spirit
woke up when he's the greatest champion
he's I think he's the greatest champion
in UFC history I really do oh look at
him go dude come on you got to give it
up that's dude you're out of your mind
you don't think he's getting his dick
sucked in Miami tonight are you kidding
me bro yeah
it's easy
that's the best three grand I've ever
lost I'm so happy dude Kid Rock likes it
lost
I'm so [__] hard well that was dice
too when he's playing that exchange game
yeah don't do it wow
no rematch huh
you never see that he's never fighting
85.
as a champion look at that Boop watch
the pier starts coming forward he plays
turtle one two okay hit me here
oh my god oh my god dude
I know I know he watches what
wow that's big head to head boom once
again right on the temple
that's the weight cut cheer you think
could be dude
also he hit him so hard he did it last
time he also hit him it could be the
punch to the face that's what I was
gonna say to the head look at Rogan but
we've seen to Cheetos point though we've
seen wow you're gonna take those punches
before but eventually it catches up with
you cutting weight like that you just
don't have the fluids
that's what I feel the way I'll be
healthy because I can't wait but I'm not
getting to 170. I'm not into 165.
appears like [__] dude that's
crazy up here jumps into it
because I mean I I you know you're gonna
believe
in three grand against them everybody
everybody they're going through fog you
one two three [__] you guys
yeah Cheeto
okay
[__] you guys
I root for him on this one wow what a
story for Izzy dude oh and three look
he's doing the body bag
I mean like that to me is a little crazy
but you know body bag well it's just
like you're you lost three times this
guy I I it's like a lot you know rare it
is to lose three times and come back and
knock it down I get it very rare [__]
rarest nobody should have bet on Izzy
although you know I did not a big deal
but the thing is is all facts and old
school statistics bad [__]
would say don't bet on Izzy but I just
bet on the dude I love it though he's a
great Champion he's so good yeah hey no
you can't come to the party like guys
let me come in no if we're in Miami
right now Izzy's like Cheeto Sam Sam you
and I will talk about my tattoos Brandon
you can come Brian I said [__] out of
here maybe the Big Slab
nope get out of here really he gave her
the stiffy
give me the mic bro amazing dude oh tell
us what he's saying George
I go to samtripley.com to find out my my
opinions he's like this is the greatest
win of my life listen Brendan child will
be in Atlanta next Thursday Friday
Saturday punch line it's the best show
on Earth Toronto that he's gonna be
insane he's doing Reno because why not
take my inspiration for Brian Collins
comedy watch watch man tears do not go
see Brian County bet against me go see
Brennan Atlanta next Thursday Friday
Saturday that's April 13th to the 15th
to be very clear you know it's funny as
[__] Sam's a great size I will never bet
against Israel alisonia again
what a bad [__] he is come on
the the the rational smart thing was to
put your money on pajera and this dude
just did The Impossible well you still
the favorite it didn't seem right him
not being a champion right like it
seemed off it seemed like watching I
agree porn just didn't seem again
it's all right got me again
why is this always recommended to me
what is wrong with my childhood
what a killer man what a bad
[__] what a crazy success dude
you know it's gonna get weird in Miami
who knows what's gonna happen in that
hotel yeah
I don't know Manny little hush man good
for him man I'm a big fan what a special
dude
oh imagine the mental strands
you're getting excited inspired I want
to fight dude you wanna fight I swear I
want to fight tomorrow yeah that's
inspiring I respect that man you're
gonna fight tomorrow Brands you do the
incline bench like I remember windy at
the comedy source
and then Dave Chappelle would walk in
and just start crushing and all I wanted
to do was get on stage and be like I
want to do that that's so motivating
success is contagious it is it's
greatness you see great like what he did
to that mental hurdle to Owen three dude
and you got knocked out you haven't been
knocked out your entire MMA crew get
knocked out and then you have the
confidence to not only go in there but
exchange with this 205er and knock them
out not to become the middleweight
champion of the world
Hamza congrats oof yeah okay you haven't
beat nobody in the top 20 in 185 don't
[__] yourself
put somebody in the top 10 and then cool
see I I think Hamza should have to fight
Whitaker or like a Marvin vittori and
then fight Izzy I don't think it's fair
for him to he beat Kevin Holland and
then jump in the fight yeah no look at
this this game plan look at this I'm
gonna say dude
by the shirt [__]
double arrows
ass off hands down
dude let's [__] shoot up
is that his brother who is that that's
it that's his dad on the right in the
blue
his brother doesn't that those are the
Nigerians
respect Nigerians man that's a that
that's all about family though they are
that's a bird in the world he's a cool
guy when when he fought in New York I
was sitting next to him you know how
hard is that oh I can't just started
crying my first reaction was just like
come on I was sitting next to his
brother
crying yeah
that was
because I I the first thing I thought
about was my family of course I mean and
now you've won in Miami that's gotta
feel good too because you're this the
king of the town for the night well dude
if the scary thing is I've picked dizzy
since day one on this uh on this was the
third fight I picked him from day one
but
the scary thing yeah Brian went against
him but the thing is is uh what's crazy
is you listen to Izzy's Coach and he's
talking about uh pierra he's talking to
who's that guy that I like uh to the
British guy PT Carol yeah pizza Carol
Petty Carol was interviewing his coach
his coach was like he's a it doesn't
make sense how hard he hits like
fundamentally like technical wise it
doesn't make sense you says a gift from
God he goes looking at his highlights
and years and I've watched everyone and
he goes I'm he's the best knockout
artist who's this which one that yeah
that's Izzy's coach saying that he goes
he's the scariest knockout artists the
UFC's ever seen so you listen like oh
[__] I guess it's a joke bro
Bosa filming them what a night the
random white guy hell yeah
dancing
good for him man
Kobe Covington right there
I'm happy for this [__] guy dude oh
dude imagine how happy is
look you just type around type type keep
typing there you go
back dancing all the way back what a
night boy it's gonna get weird for him
tonight yeah yeah I can feel to my bones
butt stuff oh yes that's inspirational
yeah we're doing Rim action dude that's
so inspirational
good for you man you deserve it and for
the UFC this is great he's he's the
biggest pay-per-view star that's what I
should look like that's my beard and my
[__] balls
you should look at the guy on the left
we're gonna look like you're on the
right
[Laughter]
yeah they look tough yeah I gotta do it
looks like he plays no [__] no he's he's
taking a lot of lives a lot of lives
foreign
wow what a feeling for Izzy dude I don't
really I mean there's homs out of 85 but
he has to earn that but outside that
he's kind of cleared the division I'm
not betting against Izzy no so you don't
think there'll be a rematch I guarantee
you there will guarantee though UFC
won't do it again because they don't
want to there's also no interest there's
no interest at all now especially after
that knockout the fourth fight's not
there because he go he goes after
winning the whole fight and now he's
creating a second it's very clear it's
very clear and then Pierre is just going
to go to 205. and is he all right maybe
when he's a little older will go up
there I don't know how much is left for
Izzy there's not much for him to do
what should we do
I'm retire is he no way not not right
now but I'd say in like two or three
fights
unless he wants to test uh 205
I don't think he does no he's a small
two or five crazy [__] but the Yuri
fight for him would be good up there the
racket fights good for him Anthony Smith
it's just you got the maguman and
collabs up there and the yawns those are
trouble other than that beautiful John
yeah yeah it was tough fight for him
Oh there's uh our boy Jeremy Renner yeah
Jerry yeah ran over by a snow machine
yeah
he uh there's a dateline special on it
it I went ahead I ran over because
things aren't fast
what did he do we're not trying to make
jokes but those things aren't like
Speedy you know get out the way they
weigh like six thousand pounds or
something no I know so they're really
slow you know yeah
but uh maybe slip today whatever asked
why the guy wore one glove
yeah because he didn't want to break his
hand no no he don't want to hurt the guy
you know he shows up to UFC events
wearing just the one glove really hoping
somebody yeah sets them off yeah
and his side socks one glove I thought
one glove art or some [__]
incredible
watermelon there was a if there was like
a tourist bus he would just walk up I
saw him saw him do that is that
Gallagher dude I saw him wearing his
Gallagher shirt in I was doing laugh
Boston and he was in the lobby wearing
his Gallagher thing with a watermelons
they're waiting to get [__]
recognized he was a Savage back in the
day right dude we never listened to his
jokes he had great jokes he was kind of
a hack right so he was just crazy
he's a comedian he died Comics are whack
jobs I know like four normal people
they're always stand up I bet are funny
but don't everybody else
Fighters but we're all Misfits Fighters
Comics it's a misfit thing yeah we're
like the real ones are out like whenever
I'm around not to be but like I feel
like if I'm around Fighters like I'm
around like seals um maybe seals I'm
around I'm just saying I'm around people
who do like things the the weird
outliers Comics are weird too like this
is crazy
when Pierre was Marching for him like
holy [__] why not keep doing that now
you see why dude
like uh Alex was like yeah
wow [__] yes
finally he got over the hump because
that's happened a bunch of fun yeah man
three euros
dude
that is so [__] crazy I still think
there's gonna be he beat a 205 right now
not immediately it's over man not
immediately no that's for sure
you know ever again you know what I did
the 185 what it will do if you want to
do that they will give him Whitaker
orbitrary
yeah listen and this isn't hate on pure
it's just Styles if they start if Pierre
State 85 they give him Whitaker who
who's on the national team in Australia
wrestling he can wrestle they get
marvatory Jared Cannon there Jeff
Brunson he's probably gonna lose he's
never gonna see Izzy again at 85. the
other matchups are worse for him Izzy
was the best matchup in the top 10 for
him outside that it gets very dice for
him now 205 there's some fun matchups
for him until until it's yawn block you
know
I want to see what he does at 85. what I
want to see that there's a pecking order
and you know me I would suck homside off
right now but he needs to fight a guy
like Whitaker or a guy like vittori or
Brunson you can't never fight 85 and
then just fight Izzy yeah that's exactly
also you put Izzy through the ringer
dude so who's here
any favors yeah giving Beretta his third
UFC fight makes no favors to the
champion no that fought a lot of [__]
people and remember the only reason why
we're tuning is because uh Izzy was such
a huge name he's the biggest draw in the
UFC outside Conor but he was the biggest
pay-per-view star so beer name was built
off is he is he did him a favor that's
that that chapter's closed man yes for
Izzy's he's like we're good this is over
Dude yes I beat him for four rounds now
I just convincedly knocked him on just
let me move on with my career you can't
we should keep running back next the 85
he's beat everybody he's beat everybody
you do Whittaker uh Hamza I guess the
winner of that because because I want to
see I want to see Whitaker hums I don't
know Whitaker's no punk for homicide
Whitaker's actually Hans that's toughest
match of baby why do you say that
because can wrestle Whittaker is
explosive
yeah dude and for homes that we haven't
seen there it'd be tough fight for him
and Whitaker is definitely not scared
that's a tough fight for hamzat he would
have been Victory twice we take it twice
yeah there's nothing for him at 85. at
85 and right now he can take
Anderson's crown and but that no this is
the new guy that defended that many
times at 205 if they're like yeah you'll
fight just uh the winner you know of
Piera in Jamal Hill or Jamal or which if
you want to be double chamberly fight
Jamal Hill because it's a straight
striking match or if racket comes back
but you just gotta avoid magamed uh and
Goliath and Jan balkovich
nightmare for Pierre or is he absolute
nightmare
boom fun night of fights I was off on
the Adrian fight and I was off on the
Rosa Junior
easy to be off
easy to be off guys yeah if you're not
if you're doing nothing and you've got
me three grits that it's easy to be off
now if you buy an incline bench you can
keep that three grand I'm gonna buy an
incline bench and it's gonna be an
Olympic one so I'd like to keep that
three grand okay listen it's the best
three grand I ever lost I wanted to lose
it yay Trump looks so bored
she's like Trump's a little bit okay
Trump's had a tough time of it he's
looking at one indictment and two more
possibly
I mean dude his lawyers are just
cha-ching I was thinking the same thing
his words were making so much money
because this process still isn't going
to be finalized they just keep coming
for us
at the end bad but is he going like he's
not going to yell no no no because that
will open the door for all of them
because then then we start looking the
Biden paper trail you look at 100
bitings my pardon him don't be surprised
it's exactly what Ford did to uh it's
what Ford did with Nixon and and it it
it it shouldn't be a surprise if Biden
actually gives him a full part I think
Nick's him what I think we have a I'm
not saying Nixon was a good guy but I
think we've been sold an image of Nixon
that I've read three of his books Nixon
is Nixon wrote a book called real peace
and look up with the books he's read
written we should end it there I don't
want all our listeners to go to sleep
Hey listen I'll be in Atlanta next week
next Thursday Friday Saturday
I like talking JFK is about to talk
about it go I'm in Atlanta next week no
what do you got nothing this Sleep King
no I'm kicked him off because he pulled
the CIA side and goes I know you killed
him
and then the bang they get them out they
make this fake thing they run them out
and they put their guy in that was a
total
CIA plan Brian how do you know so who
killed said to the CIA it's on tapes
Brian it's audio tapes Sam I don't think
so
it's Sam this is where we get a little
prince oh the bunch of people Sam see I
who killed Kennedy CIA yeah
Federal Reserve
um the mob Federal Reserve
now don't worry about it no I'm not okay
no no I did not say I did not say that
wrap it up time to go yep that's great
Atlanta next Thursday Friday Saturday
the La Jolla comedy story June 2nd the
4th but I'm with the great Sam tripley
Tuesday night 10 p.m at the comedy store
and then starting June 13th I'm over in
Europe in Belfast don't worry about mine
ending in Dublin no Sam's all over as
well
I'm in The Comedy Store on Tuesday
Toronto Reno San Diego just
gosamford.com feel it you guys want to
learn about Nixon I'll be uh in Portland
April 2021 helium Cheetah Girls is going
to be opening up for me and doing a
seminar dude you could crush it bro
after fighting like give you guys a
holler bro I'll give you guys a holler
you come open for me you're the funniest
guy in the show
thanks for doing it thanks everybody
love you
and I'll see you next week